this is Jocko podcast number 402 with
Echo Charles and me Jocko willink good
evening Echo good evening
my
my son went to a wrestling camp when he
was younger
and not just any wrestling camp a
wrestling camp known as the j-rob
Intensive wrestling camp and these are
camps that were started in 1978. by
national Hall of Fame wrestler Jay
Robinson
and Jay Robinson competed in the 1970
1971 World Wrestling Champion chips he
placed fourth and fifth he competed in
the 1972 Olympics he was a three-time
NCAA Champion head coach at the
University of Minnesota
where they also won Big Ten Big Ten
titles
and he coached 14 individual national
champions
so very distinguished as a wrestler and
as a coach and he also had served in the
military
he was in the Vietnam War he was an
Airborne Ranger in the Army and
that service clearly had an influence on
J rob his attitude and his camps
and I recognize that when my son went to
his camp
they're taught something called the j7
the j7 the j7 are these
what they say the necessary fundamentals
to build a fulfilling and successful
life
and I think you'll see that these things
well obviously help person build a good
life but also turn them into a damn good
wrestler here's the here's the j7 the
seven fundamentals number one discipline
doing what you don't want to do when you
don't want to do it number two
dedication your ability to commit day
after day sacrifice number three
you have to give up something to get
something
number four hard work
you can outwork 90 of all Americans
number five responsibility you are in
charge of the decisions you make who you
are and what you do number six
accountability you must own the
decisions you make that affect your life
and number seven service
give back to your community and make a
difference
so
these things are all
well they're all simple straightforward
things that we've all heard before
they're not easy for sure
they're all obviously things that I talk
about a lot
but that camp
and wrestling as a whole left a huge
mark on on my son and my daughters as
well
and it's been awesome to watch wrestling
we've seen the rise of wrestlers in MMA
and in the UFC
huge list of
I I mean Mark Coleman Mark Kerr Tito
Ortiz Randy Couture Kevin Randleman Cain
Velasquez Dominic Cruz Brock Lesnar
Weidman Rashad John Jones
Rampage Henry sujudo right there's been
some there's been some just epic
wrestlers in the sport
coming up
and right now what's neat if you're
paying attention to this sport of the
UFC there's another generation coming
into the sport right now another
generation of
American wrestlers the Next Generation
and
at the head of the pack the shiny
example of that next Generations is a
fighter and a wrestler
named Bo nickel
beau's a four-time All-American
three-time national champion
who was 135 and five in his college
career
61-0 in his last two seasons
and after competing in Freestyle
Wrestling he made the transition to MMA
where he's now
5-0
all first round stoppages four of those
five in the first minute
uh a beast on the mat a beast in the
cage but also an exemplary human being
and everybody says great teammate son
husband soon to be father
and it's an honor to have him here with
us tonight to talk about his life
his experiences and his lessons learned
bow nickel thanks for joining us man
yeah thank you appreciate it we're up
here at origin Jiu Jitsu Camp by the way
so we're a couple hours from getting a
seminar from you on some I'm assuming
we're gonna do some takedowns well I was
thinking we were talking earlier I was
going to show guard you know pull pull
guard retention maybe so well you
already how many submissions you have
you have at least one triangle I
remember yeah I did a yeah triangle arm
triangle rear naked choke I have a few
submissions but that triangle's from
your back yeah and then you kind of
transitioned yeah yeah I started an
amount but I like I like the triangle I
don't like to throw it from guard but
I'll start from Mount and then and then
basically go to my back from there but
once I lock it up I feel comfy that's
got to be um very interesting for in
your brain for you rewiring your brain
for that kind of stuff can you even
rewire your brain so I think with my
wrestling style I was really never
afraid to go to my back like kind of
high risk car reward go to my back to
you know
flip somebody or do something like that
so the Jiu Jitsu portion of it it
doesn't really freak me out a lot I
think most wrestlers kind of maybe Panic
or it's not but I mean it doesn't really
feel that weird to me I don't know yeah
I like I love it though I wish I did Jiu
Jitsu my entire life but even better I
get to start when I'm 27. yeah you're
catching up quick well let's get let's
start at the beginning let's go through
kind of where you came from how you got
here today so
you're born in Colorado is that right
yep right in Colorado and how long did
you live there for so I lived in
Colorado for the first you know four or
five years of my life do you remember it
at all yeah or anything oh you do yeah
so that's where my parents met my mom's
originally from Colorado my dad's from
Wyoming and my dad's first job was as a
wrestling coach and a football coach at
us at her old high school yeah and so
she was coming back
um from she was so he was right out of
college she was still in college and she
was coming back in the summer to like
help out the basketball team and stuff
and they just kind of they met and
basically got set up by the principal at
the school and uh obviously got along
well and stuff and that's where I was
born and so what was your dad's
wrestling career so it actually goes
back a little further than that's my
grandpa wrestled um his whole life
Russell in college was a wrestling coach
and then my dad wrestled his whole life
and played football and then he ended up
playing football in college but when he
graduated college
um got like I said a job as a wrestling
coach and a football coach and he just
just always loved it so you know it's
been in my family for a few generations
and what didn't you was your mom an
athlete too yeah so my mom played
college basketball and she did a bunch
of sports growing up and uh a bunch of
sports
um post College too she did women's
professional football she boxed some
um she did some wrestling she she just
loves sports in general so yeah so that
school principal was thinking he's going
to make a athletic Wonder yeah right
yeah I think that's jeans right yeah
exactly exactly and so then you how long
did you live there for yeah so that was
there just as a kid five years and then
I moved from Colorado to Wyoming where
my uh dad's family's from so it was just
you know a few hours away but
um my granddad my grandpa he was
coaching and he had a heart attack and
so my dad wanted to be closer to family
and kind of then like take over his
position and uh start coaching his alma
mater his wrestling team so then I lived
there for I don't know until I was 12 or
so and so wait this is in this is in
Wyoming Wyoming yeah so this is where
your wrestling started was in Wyoming I
I Wrestled a little bit in Colorado
though like my very first kind of
practices and and but not really like I
was you know five years old so really it
started in Wyoming where uh my dad was
running the high school program running
the youth program and I was kind of just
just really getting into it starting to
get some actual matches and stuff like
that what approach did he take this
because I get asked this question
five times a day in some cases what
approach did your dad take because
obviously he wanted you to wrestle right
and a lot of people they want their kids
to do something yeah for me A lot of
times people are asking about Jiu Jitsu
but what approach did your dad take that
you didn't feel like you oh my dad's
making me do this and it's forced on me
and I hate it because there's people
that right end up in that situation what
approaches your mom and dad take you
know I think that there's a couple
things that are important I think that
one I was just around it a lot you know
when I I was born in January and so
February is generally the highest did
they plan that I don't know they might
have uh I tried to plan it so my wife's
due date is like the very end of
December so I'm hoping for like one like
like a week late so we'll see but I
don't know they might have but it worked
out really well and uh but but
um back to what I was saying the state
rest wrestling tournament is generally
like february-ish and so I was like a
month old at my first day wrestling
tournament so I've just literally been
around it my entire life and I think
that I always gravitated towards it for
some reason but
I think a big part of why I didn't ever
feel pressured to wrestle was because I
did other sports too like I said my dad
played college football and so I played
football baseball soccer I ran track I
did swimming like I did every sport you
could do growing up and wrestling was
always the one I was probably best at
and that I liked the most but there was
a lot of breaks and I think that if you
take a five-year-old or a six-year-old
and you tell them they're going to be a
wrestler and they're going to wrestle in
college it's like they're just a kid you
know and like let you gotta let him be a
kid let them figure things out let them
do different stuff figure out what they
like and I think it was I was just lucky
that
not necessarily lucky but I was just in
a position where I was around wrestling
the most I just also happened to like it
the most and at the same time I could
get a break from it as a kid when you
know football season I was playing
football or you know doing soccer
playing soccer it was always wrestling
was the most important but it wasn't the
exclusive priority at that age if you
would have been more into football would
your dad have been cool yeah for sure if
you would have been more into basketball
would your dad have been cool yeah I
think so you know if you'd have been I
don't know about basketball I was gonna
say what if you were born to like
literature yeah you know
um I think that one of the things that
is
good is that my dad and I just really
bonded over wrestling because he was a
coach and he loved it it was this thing
that he was you know passionate about
and excited about and we shared that
right so he was the person from when I
was born to 18 that I spent an insane
amount of time with more time than
anybody else and we just really bonded
over that and so it definitely brought
us closer and I think if I would have
been into something different that
YouTube have just as supportive and just
as but but it wasn't his passion as well
so I think because we did share that it
just created a really strong
relationship for us but
yeah I mean I believe that my dad just
he loves me he wants me to be successful
and happy at whatever I do and I have
three younger sisters and he was super
supportive and and you know happy for
them to do they were all athletes too
but you know I'm sure if they would have
done I feel like if they would have done
something different that it would have
been you know a very supportive
environment what kind of temperament
does your dad have
so it's very interesting my dad I would
describe it as he's very calm very
relaxed
um pretty
um
pretty like uh easy to get along with
he's very friendly but he does have this
other side of him that's
like like he's a leader he's like
getting it done and he's very
um like he always ran programs right
like he was a head coach at right when
he graduated college 24 and that's what
he's done his whole life and uh so he
has that side and and it can
bring out like
a demanding part and also a a harder
part so you know I think that my dad
just had a great balance because
he pushed me and there was a lot of
discipline and a lot of structure but
there was never fear I never really was
scared of
like
my dad being mad at me it was more like
there was a some type maybe I didn't
understand this fully as a kid but there
was some type of like understanding of
all right at the end of the day like if
if this doesn't go my way my dad still
loves me he just wants me to win and he
wants me to be successful and do my best
I never felt like
it was all we were always on the same
team if that makes sense yeah I never
felt like we were fighting against each
other well if you lost when you were
12 years old
because you did something like you did
one of these risky moves that you talk
about you doing yeah and you lost what
would your dad say to you so it's kind
of funny
um
in the moment you just see things
differently and then you know you take a
little time and you can look back and
and see it for I think more of reality
and there were times where I would lose
and feel like
he was mad at me but I would take a day
or take a week and realize
or or we would just continue to have a
conversation about it and he was never
mad at me for losing a lot of times as a
kid you know like if I lost then I would
throw fit or or you know be mad at the
ref or blame somebody else for me losing
that's he would that was not okay like
that was where I would get disciplined
right like I was getting he was getting
after me but
most the time like if I lost and I was
just crushed defeated he was the first
one there for me to pick me up and tell
me that he loved me and that he's proud
of me and give me hug and stuff because
you know I was just a very different kid
I think
at a young age at six seven eight years
old I knew what I wanted to do and so it
meant a lot to me it wasn't a kid
that lost and threw a fit because
you know they're just being a kid it was
like it really crushed me and so I think
that he saw that Rick you saw your hopes
and dreams being destroyed it was like
my identity like like I'm seven or eight
or whatever and I would lose and it was
like
it would just like defeat me and it
would just it would last a long time
with me I think that's part of what
motivated me a lot and helped me get to
you know where I got in my wrestling
career but yeah that that's when you
know there was a difference in
his demeanor when I would complain or
make an excuse versus just be hurt you
know yeah there's an interesting thing
I've been talking a lot about lately
when from a leadership perspective when
you're in charge of a team
you as a leader have to sort of often be
the counter
to what the team is doing from a morale
perspective so the team wins and they're
all happy and they're all like yeah
we're the best you're the one that the
leader needs to say hey yeah that was a
good job but here's some mistakes we
made you got to pull them back down when
the team loses and they're all bummed
out as a leader you got to say hey guys
yeah we lost but we learned these
lessons here's where we're gonna improve
them so that's a very good point that
sounds like your dad found that same
exact thing if you lose and you're
crushed he's not saying you're damn
right you lost you should have lost no
he's saying hey you know here's the
lesson you learned you're not going to
make that mistake again and if you won
or if you lost and you were blaming
other people blaming the ref whatever
then he's gonna tighten you up and just
pull you back in that other direction
that sounds like a really good way to
handle things yeah you know I I don't
know I think that he it was definitely
coming from a foundation of just love
loving me wanting me to be successful
while also being passionate about what
we were doing but now look back in I see
so many kids who well I mean not kids
anymore they're adults now but who
wrestled their whole life and who hate
it now or don't have a great
relationship with their dad and I'm a
lot there's a lot of questions in my
mind I'm like how did we end up like
that like that's crazy that me and my
dad are still so close and he coached me
and we spent so much time together and
you know when the vast majority of
people that were in a similar situation
to me they don't really have the same
feelings
I think a lot of that comes down to
alignment right because if there's a
little meme out there one of those
little videos and it's it's it's Matt
Damon the actor and he's yelling at a
kid
and they have like a a picture of a of
the kid's bedroom and there's like a
squat rack in there and a pull-up bar
and like a bed yeah and and you know
he's saying you know after I remodeled
my kid's room or something and the kid's
like Dad I don't want to be like this
deep it nieces you need to do this he
says why are you yelling at me
because it's a good dream
and so I they clearly like that kid's
not aligned with the dad but for you
luckily you guys were aligned and I
think what you as a this is my
experience what you have to do as a
parent what I have to do as a parent
what parents have to do is your kids
there's a decent chance like hey you
might get lucky and your kid happens to
want to be
you know a wrestling champion or
whatever and that's what you're into
cool but if you want your kid to be a
wrestling champion and they don't want
to be a wrestling champion that's where
there's going to be a problem just like
in a marriage you know if you if you
wanna
make a bunch of money and that's what
you're focused on but your wife wants to
have quality time with the family
there's a lack of alignment there and
it's going to be a problem so it sounds
like you two were aligned my
recommendation for people is you have to
align yourself with what your kids want
and look if your kids you can kids are
going to go through some phases where
they want to do some dumb stuff right so
we're not going to go there but as they
grow up they find out what they're
interested they find what their passion
is and you gotta you gotta kind of get
aligned with them that's what you that's
what you kind of have to do now you say
you knew
how did you know what did you know how
old were you and you knew I would say
when I first knew what I wanted to do
um I was probably like seven you know
like you know that that's at that point
I knew
just from being what around
who I was around my dad was coaching
individual state champions state
championship teams guys that were going
to college competing on a national level
and so
I saw that and I knew that's what I want
to do you know at that moment it was
like all right I want to be a state
champion you know in high school and
obviously in Youth and stuff and
after I do that like I want to be a
national champion I want to be a world
champion and so it was really you know
just
my environment and seeing people that
that was a reality for and uh
very young you know I think I used to
have this old uh TV there was like the
big box with the you could put the VHS
in the bottom and I had a VHS tape of
I want to say it was the 2002 it was
either 2002 or 2003 NCAA finals like I I
got like that was maybe the first year
they ever broadcast on ESPN and kale
Sanderson was
um
that was the year he won his fourth NCAA
title and so
um I would watch that like every night
like over and over and over again and
you know so that was yeah like I said I
was born in 96 so I was six or seven
years old and I knew like that's what I
wanted to do I had my dad get me the
same red head gear like like kale and
um you know when I got more access to
film for that we used to have this DVD
set of the best the best Olympic trials
in world world championship trials
matches so it'd have John Smith Randy
Lewis best two out of three Kenny Monday
Dave Schultz best two out of three all
these crazy amazing wrestlers that
competed um that's what I was watching
as a kid I wasn't watching like Disney
or movies or stuff like that we'd go on
a road trip to wherever and my sisters
would be so mad because I would throw
wrestling in the in the DVD player and
that was just when I was a kid and it
was just what I loved and you know I
could automatically kind of just see a
difference between
me and
kind of the other kids that I was around
what they're interested in and even a
difference between me and the the kids I
was around that were wrestlers that were
competing at a high level just by
how much time I spent
kind of obsessing over the sport just
because I loved it like I didn't really
have anybody
my dad never made me do that my dad made
me go to practice and he made me train
and you know he would take me to
tournaments but outside of that there
was a lot that went into it that was
just my decision
well what age were you when you started
training year round
see that's that's another interesting
question because
I wasn't
full-time wrestling until I was a junior
in high school dang yeah so I I played
football
I so I did tons of sports basically
through
eighth grade and then in eighth grade
wrestling and football and then 9th 10th
wrestling football and then there was
honestly a time where I thought hey I
love wrestling so much but
I could probably play college football
too like that was in my in my mind and
uh you know once I got a little older I
realized that
I just love wrestling too much it's just
too fun for me it's too exciting and
football is really fun but
I just identify with it on a different
level it's more of the
the team camaraderie that that aspect of
sport that I really like but
wrestling was just more me you know it's
it's me out there and and it's more my
personality I've had in a day win or
loses on me I want it to be that way I
don't want to rely on it whether I'm not
a kicker makes a field goal in the last
10 seconds like for us to win you know I
I'm just not that that that didn't fit
my personality as well well they say
that that that that
specialization of young kids isn't as
good as people think it is it's better
to have them do a wide variety of sports
they just become more overall athletic
so apparently that worked with you I
would 100 agree with that I think that
when I look at a lot of my teammates in
college who only wrestled their whole
life they're really only able to kind of
move in one kind of way there's not a
lot of
different
differentiation of movement in general
it's kind of like that's how they move
and uh but I see guys that do other
sports and it's very unique right and I
think they just kind of have maybe more
upside and uh in addition to that I
think it's I said I don't identify with
the team sports as much but I do love
team sports and that that social
component and having to work together is
such a big part of of sport in general
that I think
socially if you start at five years old
and you only ever do an individual sport
golf tennis wrestling you know
you kind of don't get that
that uh socialization of competing
together with people and having to
uh work as a team and know know your
your part and your place and and do that
so to me I'm grateful for having done
sports for for those two reasons right
like the the physical aspect of being
able to move differently but also the
the social aspect of knowing how to
interact with people and how to deal
with teammates and how to kind of
struggle together but also
um like come out on the other end and
like win together
what were you doing with school like
actual school work did you care did you
try were you like
no so I don't know
um why but I've just always was
good at school like it was easy for me I
never studied
um the first time I ever studied for
anything was probably my freshman year
of college and I mean in high school I
basically I never got a B I was like
straight A's
elementary school middle school high
school and I think that
you know I I liked certain aspects of
school I liked math I liked history
um and the other to me it was just like
I'm just gonna do my best regardless of
what I'm doing and and that was my best
I think in college I lost that a little
bit the first couple years because
I just didn't care I was like I'm here
to Russell let's be real like no this is
this is what I'm here for so I'm not
gonna kid around so you know I'd miss
class here and there and
um my my kind of got away from a little
bit of that I mean I still did well in
school I had like you know 3.0 or
something like that but it wasn't what I
could have been doing and I just
remember my coach came up to me and was
like
talking to me about on my coach I don't
like I'm gonna wrestle like I'm not
gonna you know I thought I wanna maybe
go to med school or something I was like
I'm not gonna do that I'm gonna wrestle
and then he's like I get it I get it but
you can't be doing this and not if
you're gonna do something you should
just do your best and I was like that's
a great point so then you know after
that it was it was all it didn't matter
to me what my grade was it was all
effort based so it was I'm not going to
miss a class that I that I'm like if I
don't have to like if I'm traveling for
wrestling obviously I have to but I'm
not gonna miss any class I'm gonna sit
in the front row I'm gonna be engaged
and my grades got a lot better I ended
up with like a three two three three
something like that and uh yeah it was I
think that's the main thing for me was
in school
just do your best that's that's it so
you didn't stay in Wyoming though did
you your next move was to New Mexico
yeah so at about fifth grade so I was
like maybe 11 12.
um my mom and dad my mom did not like
Wyoming it was like crap weather we
lived in a town of 5 000 people and it
was just not really her type of
environment you know and uh so then
and in addition to that it was just a
small town you know my parents were
looking for good opportunities for
myself or my sisters and so my dad got a
head coaching job offer in New Mexico at
a school called Rio Rancho which had
wanna like honestly one of the top
programs in the country there was tons
of kids there that were just super super
high level and uh
you know my mom was like this is
definitely a little better weather and
the environment's a little nicer and
stuff so
um
made the move there and uh yeah lived
there for a few years and that's really
where
I started I was serious about wrestling
before that but that's where I started
almost doubling down on it even more but
you still weren't trained in full time
no so basically my schedule would be
um
you know the four months I'll get like
maybe end of July August through
October
football but
and and it depended like I would
probably hit one or two wrestling
training sessions a week
um
and then maybe like I would do one one
tournament or something like that like
during football season but it was it was
mainly just football I'd have those
three four months out of the year to
just focus on football and then this
summer I would do other sports tracker
baseball but
the other sports weren't as serious it
would be like
you know I would just basically still be
doing a full wrestling schedule through
those Sports oh so you were training
year round
yeah
oh yeah I was I was training I would say
this I was training if you look at it
cumulative is probably 10 months out of
the Year okay I just did everything I
just loved it so other than football
season you're wrestling yeah yeah and
you you made Varsity your eighth grade
when you were in eighth grade yeah so um
it's interesting interesting I weighed
100 pounds so it's 103 at the time yeah
so basically uh
what was gonna happen was I had a really
good football team
um that year and I was also a little
small so I mean not not like super small
but like somewhat small so between
seventh and eighth grade we were all
going to get held back and it was going
to be like create this super team for
sports and it was gonna be insane and uh
all the parents got together we were
just like yo we're doing this yeah and
it was like okay let's do it and so
yeah and and and but we were all on
board all the kids because those were
all like my best friends so I was like
yeah let's do this and then Wabi just
basically do this do this year over and
so we we go to do it and uh they're like
okay everybody all these other kids can
do it but you can't do it and I was like
and they're like your state test scores
are too high we can't allow you to get
held back and I'm like what the frick
but like this doesn't make any sense
they're like you scored at this grade
level whatever like there's no way to
we're just not gonna allow it and they
like put their foot down nobody taught
you how to bomb the test yet yeah I know
I should have but
um I was just like what are we gonna do
and my my dad was just super pissed
because they let everybody go besides me
and so my dad's like are you're gonna
get homeschooled this year
and so in eighth grade I was
homeschooled and I just wrestled and I
played on my football team too but did
you still repeat the year then as a
homeschooler no so I didn't repeat the
year so basically we kind of just
decided that
since oh yeah so so since I had to move
up a grade
to stay with my football team I
basically because it wasn't a a school
team it was a club team got it I I
couldn't do eighth grade because the the
years in school were like kind of weird
where like Middle School is six seventh
and then it was like the schedule didn't
work out so we're gonna homeschool you
we're gonna have you do football and
then you're allowed to do as a
homeschool athlete the high school
technically has to a lot like your local
has to allow you to do one sport and so
obviously I'm gonna do wrestling and
um
in New Mexico you can compete on varsity
as an eighth grader because of just the
way that state works like there's some
states that just allow that and so
that year was really interesting because
my parents were both working full-time
their teachers and coaching and stuff
and I was just at home
like I basically took a register here
and like it worked out and you're 13. I
was like 13. so
I would wake up I would work out I would
do like a P90X workout I don't know if
y'all even know this but I remember yeah
yeah I'll do a b90x workout and uh then
my parents the first couple weeks
they're like there's people like
Googling P90X right now gonna sign up
for that yeah yeah and so they're like
all right here's all your school stuff
it's on the computer you know you got
history you got math you got whatever
all these classes and I was like okay so
I did them for a week and then my
parents like weren't really checking I
was like I'm not doing that I'm done so
I didn't I didn't do school I just
basically took that whole year and I
worked out and wrestled and did and
played football at the beginning but it
was mostly just working on wrestling and
the wrestling was just with the high
school yeah so what I would do was and
what I had been doing up to you know
from fifth grade on is and I would do
the high school practice which would be
a little earlier so it'd be like right
after school 3 30 P.M to 5 30 p.m and
then I'll go straight to Club Practice 6
30 to whatever eight so I would do
that's like four and a half hours of
wrestling yeah most days that's what I
was doing I would do two yeah and then I
would lift them I like the fact that
earlier said you weren't like a
full-time person but here you are just
doing nothing but wrestling I just loved
it I homeschooled my son for a few years
and you sound like he had a very similar
schedule but it was all surfing a new
chance
yeah not much it was great for me I mean
it worked out because I was somebody
that I didn't really
it was just what I needed at the time
you know were your sisters no you're
just home alone so I had one sister
she's a year younger than me that she
was homeschooled as well so it was me
and her and we would just hang out but
you're 13 years old home by yourself
just doing whatever yeah what did you
eat dude dude the worst I would like
well it wasn't all bad it was like 50
the worst but I would make brownies like
every day I would literally I learned
how to make brownies with the old uh
like Betty Crocker box or whatever and I
would just like make a tray of brownies
and eat them every day I don't even
think my parents knew
and I would watch movies I would watch
like uh the one movie I watched 100
times I watched Joe Dirt
I just thought it was the funniest thing
in the world
how'd you do your your varsity or your
freshman year or your eighth grade year
how did you do I did okay
um so our team was very good so we would
travel all over we'd go to you know we'd
go up to Colorado we'd go to Kansas we'd
go to California we'd wrestle and you
know all kinds of big tournaments and I
don't remember how many times I lost
probably
four or five times and uh I ended up
taking second in the state which crushed
me it was the worst like I wanted to be
I never lost to the state tournament so
from the time I was
six when I did my first state tournament
in wrestling
uh youth wrestling freestyle Greco folk
style so three three state tournaments a
year I never lost that estate tournament
until the eighth grade my first year of
Varsity make the finals and I'm actually
wrestling kid that was an old teammate
of mine who transferred to a different
School
and who I'd beat uh I beat a couple
times he beat me maybe once and he
freaking he got me and it was
devastating it was it was it was hard
but uh yeah I mean overall it was a it
was like he was the same age as you no
he was like three or four years older
yeah because that's the thing people got
to understand is
in high school when you're wrestling
you're wrestling by weight but you know
different people have different subjects
in life and so you can you you were
probably off actually probably you were
probably always resting guys that were
17 or 18 years old yeah you were 13. so
what my dad would do this is funny but
when I turned I think it started when I
turned nine so when I went up till nine
I was probably wrestling like at six and
seven and eight probably 40 50 matches a
year at nine it was like I already done
this for real I was wrestling like over
100 matches a year what I would do is
I'd wrestle the nine tens I would
wrestle eleven twelve soda under Russell
10 and under I wrestled 12 and under and
I would wrestle 20 matches in a weekend
sometimes it was like insane and then
by the time I graduated the the 10 and
under division so when I turned 11 I
would wrestle 11 12 and then the next
division was 15 and under so I was 11
and I'd wrestled 15 year olds and that
was the standard for me and I wasn't
just doing like local tournaments like
this I'll go to like a a big tournament
with kids from 20 different states and I
would wrestle as an 11 year old I
wrestled 11 12 and I'd wrestle
13 14 15 as well so I'd also like I said
20 matches in a weekend and competing
against everybody my dad was just trying
to get me get me matches yep so uh I
just have to send out some advisory
information here because I did that too
with my kids yeah and and it wasn't good
because I would put my kids when they
were
younger
lower belts and and lower they were
lower weights and make them wrestle up
age make them wrestle up belts and make
make them wrestle up weights
and so they'd get their asses kicked
sometimes yeah and
I would in my mind you know my inner
dialogue was like I'm making really
tough kicks and in their minds it was
I'm not good at this I suck you know I
suck this isn't fun I don't want to do
this and
what you want your kids to do is have
fun that's what you want and winning is
fun right losing is not fun I I think
I'm trying to remember where I got this
from maybe it's huberman
but
I don't know who it is eighty percent
Jordan Peterson Jordan Peterson 80
that's what you want you want to win 80
of the time so if you can get your kids
to win 80 of the time that's good 20
time they lose then they oh I can do
this and they feel good about themselves
you don't want to do 20 win and 80 lose
because then they don't want to practice
they don't want to get better
uh how often were you winning when you
were 11 years old going against 15 year
olds yeah so I'll disagree with him a
little bit because if I would have lost
two matches every 10 matches I wrestled
I would have been Furious I would like
been so mad so I probably won 95 of my
matches you know I was probably if I
wrestled 100 matches in the year I would
lose you know four or five
um
but those kids that were four years
older than you yeah and there would be
kids that were my age that would be me
too you know like I would go to there
was this big tournament Tulsa Nationals
like Tulsa Nationals was the tournament
you get kids from everywhere and I never
won it as a kid I would always be you
know second third like right in there I
never did I always placed high but I
never I never won like one year
I actually took sixth and if you look at
it there's this crazy picture online
where
if you look at the six guys there's like
10 national titles 17 All-American
honors like multiple world champions
it's like crazy like in this Tulsa
Nationals you know you look is I'm
trying to remember the guys it was Dean
Heil who's multiple time National
Champion Joey McKenna uh Ohio State
wrestler Zach Hall Isaiah Martinez
um Anthony Valencia there was maybe like
one other guy and and me and I was and I
I was the sixth out of all of those guys
but uh yeah so I was losing
at a pace that for me was was good it
was like every loss would really hit me
hard but it would I would be motivated
from it right yeah and I think that
you know if you're a parent and your kid
is obviously doing well I like for
instance let's say you hadn't wrestled
as much and you got into it when you
were in eighth grade and your dad your
dad wouldn't throw you to the Tulsa
tournament not let you get annihilated
because he would have been like oh no
we're gonna go over and beat up some of
these kids in this local tournament it's
all good yeah
um it's interesting this whole this
whole personality that you have that you
sat here for like 15 minutes and said
that you didn't really wrestle that much
as a kid and it turns out you were
competing 100 matches a year oh man this
is not normal
I'll say this it I wasn't exclusive
exclusively wrestling I was doing it a
lot obviously like as we can tell you
know I was seven eight years old
wrestling I mean by the time I was 10 I
had probably 500 matches you know like
crazy but
um
but it was to me
not the only thing I had like I had a
lot of other things going on as well I
don't know well the big question to me
is I don't know how my parents managed
it because they were both working my dad
was coaching he was traveling with his
team like how he missed
in my whole youth all the way up until I
got to college one Tournament of mine
and I did terrible I was like 12. and I
was like got wrecked but uh yeah I mean
my whole youth I'm like the math doesn't
really check out there because he has a
full-time job and he's also coaching a
team
so how does this work but I'm just like
he did it so was he your coach always in
high school yeah yeah so basically what
happened was that helps obviously yeah
so
up until the eighth grade we lived in
New Mexico he was always the head coach
of the high school he would have
obviously assistance and then you know
run the youth program as well so he was
with me coaching me
um every day and then uh
when I after the eighth grade from
eighth to ninth grade my sisters were
getting a little older we started to
realize New Mexico
it was it had a lot of good things but
the culture wasn't great a lot of a lot
of gangs a lot of like you know drugs
just kind of bad stuff we're near
Albuquerque it was a rougher area that's
also kind of where I started fighting
where I started getting interested in
fighting because big fight culture in
that area but
um they just didn't really want it
wasn't really me it was more so my
sister's kind of coming up in that type
of environment so we were looking for
places to go that
had great wrestling and were more of a
family type environment and so we ended
up moving to Texas
and my dad also didn't want to he was
spending so much time coaching and
wrestling he wanted to spend some more
time with my sisters and uh he decided
to kind of take a back seat and just be
be a dad be and maybe do like some
assistant coaching work and once we got
to Texas he basically just coached me
and that was it and he wasn't like a
fish he was a teacher but he didn't
coach like on the high school team
officially until the coach was like
please like help us and then now you
said in New Mexico you started getting
uh and I quote interested in fighting
does that mean you're getting scraps oh
yeah oh yeah so I always kind of
but just being like a a boy in wrestling
and playing football it's like that's a
normal thing right like scrapping but in
New Mexico it really got turned up to
like 100 because we're right near
Jackson's that was right when all these
dudes were coming out of there that were
absolute Killers you know Rashad Evans
cage our Dean cowboy store like tell me
so many guys and uh so that was just
such a normal thing so what we do at
these tournaments first off like my
friends and I would just fight it'd be
like oh let's just fight for fun you
know and uh then what we started doing
was we'd go to wrestling tournament
local tournament at a high school or
whatever and we'd get
you know 15 20 kids right and we go back
hallway where nobody was you know uh the
Germans in the gym we'd go out the gym
through the cafeteria or whatever and
find a back hallway where no parents
were nobody was and we just get in a
circle and we just fight so you'd rustle
your match boom you go out there you'd
fight you'd go wrestle you go fight so I
would get like 10 wrestling matches and
I would like fight 10 kids at the same
time like the same day and uh that was
just what I what I started doing it was
just fun I just loved it but it was uh
yeah a little crazy but that's just kind
of where I first got introduced to to
fighting and and and saw it as something
that I was just I was like I like this
you know yeah right on now moving to
Texas wrestling's not huge in Texas and
did your dad he must have looked at like
Pennsylvania Iowa like he must
California what what made him settle in
Texas yeah so yeah we looked at
um Iowa City you looked at Blair Academy
in New Jersey we looked at Poway
um all could it could have been out
there which would have been crazy but
yeah all these schools very good um
so I remember my mom my dad and I were
driving out to Texas
um to kind of just scope the area take
the job interviews and stuff and uh so I
get there and the people were just so
nice right away just awesome people the
high school was massive the football
team was like the number one team in the
country they had all these crazy plans
they had all this strength conditioning
stuff in place with with the high school
and everything was like it seemed like a
college it was insane and uh so my
parents saw that they had a high school
science teacher which that's what my dad
does and they had a Middle School PE
teacher which is what my mom does like
those jobs were available and it was
like okay that's a little weird that
these two jobs are perfectly already
available so they interview they get the
jobs on the spot and then they're like
okay like give us like a day to think
about it and we're driving back and
this is we we just found out about
basically the high school I went to was
Allen High School we found out about
this place
five days earlier maybe less and then
you know got the jobs and they're
driving back and my parents were just
like
if this isn't God telling us where we
need to be like I don't even know so
call back accept the jobs and then the
next week I moved to Texas and lived
that summer with
um one of my now best friends and uh his
family and just did their summer
strength conditioning program and did
like some summer football and stuff and
uh wrestled obviously and then my
parents and sisters moved out like the
end of the summer so it was it happened
so fast it was like oh we're in New
Mexico but we're kind of interested in
other places and then a week later I was
in Texas it was like insane and did you
so you played football too yeah I played
football for two years there and uh the
high school team's insane so
um I think my freshman sophomore year
they were maybe State quarterfinals
State semis but then my junior senior
year and the next like two or three
years
state champion number one team in the
country 60 game unbeaten street now the
quarterback when I was in school was uh
Kyler Murray he's the quarterback for
the Arizona Cardinals they have like I
don't even know probably 10 guys that
were on the team that play in the NFL
now yeah so the team was stacked and and
I I love playing and stuff
um but I just I after it's so different
in Texas when you're playing football
it's not football season it's first off
we're gonna do football season it's 16
weeks it's 12 regular season games and
or 10 regular season games in six
playoffs it's like it's a lot you go
till Christmas and then as soon as
you're done with that it's our power
lift in the next three months okay we're
done powerlifting we got full pad Spring
ball season so there's whatever 12 weeks
of full pad Spring ball okay summer
seven on seven we're going to Arkansas
we're going to Oklahoma we're playing
seven on seven it's like that's all year
for them so I did it for two years and I
was
I was playing well and like I probably
would have been you know a
I wouldn't have been the best player on
the team but I would have been a guy
that contributed a lot on the team and
stuff and I was like
but I wasn't committed like these other
kids I was like I'm not gonna not
wrestle like I'm not like I'm doing well
in season but I'm not gonna take all
this and I do Spring ball but I can't do
everything else so in my mind I had to
pick I just got to an age where I was
like I gotta pick a path how'd you do
your freshman year in wrestling so my
freshman year of wrestling I did well I
had a couple losses
um I had gotten a little bigger so my
eighth grade I was about 100 pounds my
freshman year I weighed about 120 125
and uh
I made the state finals again as a
freshman and uh had an insane match with
this kid who was a senior who's like
two-time defending state champion and he
ended up beating me and so I got second
again and
crushed me I just remember like oh that
was probably
up to that point in my life is
definitely the hardest thing that I had
which it seems like you know I'm very
blessed like I didn't have a lot of like
trauma outside of that but that was the
hardest thing I had to deal with because
like it was like all right well I can't
be a five-time state champion which I
was never really like a big thing on my
mind I was like but I'm gonna win every
year when I'm actually in high school
and then boom can't do it and I'm like
oh like I just ran straight out into the
parking lot and just like
was crushed for an hour my dad came got
me I was like hey you gotta get your
medal like you gotta go on the podium
like take a picture and I was like no
I'm not doing that and he was like no
come on you gotta but yeah it was rough
how long did it take you to get through
that
so did you like immediately Dan Gable
just like start training even harder
um
yeah kind of you know um it was right
after that you know I I had like I don't
really remember I kind of like blank it
out to be honest you know I know that
summer I was wrestling at Fargo National
tournaments and I did okay and stuff and
um but I was still like I just kind of
just had so much going on between just
being a kid and school and football and
wrestling that I was just it was just
like right back on it you know and and I
didn't really I don't think it process
that a lot but uh
it was it it was something that it
motivated me because of how bad I hurt
so anytime I go into a training session
that's what I would think about I would
just be like
dude you want to feel that again or are
you going to like are you gonna wimp out
on this workout you want to feel like
that like that's what are you going to
do yeah yeah my my daughter after she
would wrestle I couldn't talk to her for
20 minutes whether she won or lost yeah
if she wanted and I went over and said
hey good job she'd be like yeah she was
not emotional yeah and then if she lost
I'd go you know that girl was tough yeah
my son no emotions win or lose just this
just look like nothing happened yeah
like he looked like he just walked out
of the grocery store you know he just
had you know an overtime match and
pinned a guy who's got pinned or
whatever and he just like I'd be like
hey good job he's like
so interesting I have videos of both of
them and you're like how are these kids
related that's so interesting yeah
totally different yeah it was always
really emotional for me
um as a kid at least because I put so
much into it so I feel like there was at
that point it was like unless I like if
I did what I wanted to do I was like ah
whatever cool I did it but if I lost it
was like crush me or if I won in a way
that I wasn't you know sufficient then I
was like insufficient yeah if it was
like insufficient winning yeah like
let's say like I was just mad because I
would be like and at that point it would
be like a lot of excuse to be like well
he was stall and he back like well this
guy wrestled me and I'd be like and then
I had to grow out of that though you
know so
um it was just yeah very very emotional
thing which I I just it was good and bad
right like if you let that control you
it's gonna end up
really affecting you a lot and it did
you know even through my college career
but once you learn you have to learn a
lot about yourself to be able to kind of
move past that and use it efficiently
versus letting it kind of dictate how
you feel are you cut and weight at this
point no not really no so I weighed 100
my freshman year I would wrestled 103.
you know I'd cut a little weight here
and there maybe my uh my freshman year I
would or excuse me eighth grade I was
100 my freshman year I was 125. I'd
maybe get up to 129. you know so nothing
I didn't cut really I never cut my
senior year high school I wrestled 182
and I weighed 170 pounds it was best for
a team for me to just be up away so
yes 12 pounds I've never been a big
weight cutter you know even in college I
started off 174.
sophomore junior I went up to 84 my
senior I was 197 when 200 maybe so I
went I was weighing probably actually
I'd finish practice 194 195 so that's
that's crazy that's just what I weighed
I just never been a weight cutter I
don't really
I always focused on getting better at
wrestling weight cutting is obviously
important part of the sport and you know
I would do it here and there but
you know I just I just wasn't interested
in doing that I was interested in
getting better
so your state champ 10th grade yeah so
that was a big like right right or wrong
for me so that was that was a big moment
I felt like all right we're kind of
turning a corner here yeah same thing
11th grade yeah it got a lot better so
that was the first year I just did
wrestling exclusively and
I went from
probably a 10 to
like like maybe like a 8 to 12 kid in
the country to like number one you still
are gonna like roll into some do meets
or something where you've got some kid
that's been wrestling for like two years
right yeah yeah so I got a good story
about that so and especially in Texas
yeah yeah there's just not good
wrestling in general like you get to the
state tournament the finals there's one
there was one division at the time so
yeah we're gonna wrestle somebody good
it's a huge State there's gonna be
somebody but
here at the District tournament or
whatever and it's like this kid might be
his first year you know and I'm like the
number one kid in the country so
I remember one year uh I we we so our
our rival in football was this School
South Lake Carroll their Dallas School
very good at football and uh
we were wrestling him in a dual meet and
I was like got all my boys I'm like yo
come out to the still it's gonna be sick
like South Lake Carol let's do it we're
getting posters in the hallways and
promoting it we never got people at the
duel so we'd get
80 people maybe because nobody cared
about wrestling our team was state champ
we won State up to this year like 13
years in a row like my high school team
like we were as a team my junior year
the top 10 team in the country we're
very good but nobody cared about
wrestling but this one duel I was like
yo like
let's get it and we had probably 600
people there you know like there was a
lot and I was like this is gonna be
crazy it's gonna be sick and I go out
and I'm looking and I'm like
this kid is so bad like he's he can't
even walk straight basically and I'm
like what am I gonna do here and and I'm
still you know young so I don't really
know and I just low single off the
whistle pull his foot and he's just like
boom falls back and I just like jumped
on him and I pinned the kid like four
seconds it was crazy like no
exaggeration I I know four seconds might
sound like a hyperbole like I'm not
exaggerating it was four seconds and
there I was like bing slap the mat and
all my buddies were like
[Laughter]
yeah and I was I was like damn I
probably shouldn't have done that I
probably should have taken him down a
few times made it cool but whatever you
know so yeah that's you would get that
once in a while with just kids it
you know don't never wrestled right like
they just they're just like oh I'll just
try wrestling like oh frick this is what
we're doing yeah you probably could have
wrestled like the entire weight class
all the way up oh yeah yeah
then so you said you're the number one
in the country right now what are they
basing that off are they basing that off
of those big like Tulsa tournaments and
stuff like that yeah so so the Tulsa
tournaments are really just youth so up
to eighth grade but then once you get
into high school there's different sets
of tournaments so they're sun-kissed
kids and those are still youth that's
still youth okay yeah so in in high
school you have the big tournaments
during the folk style season are the
Iron Man
um
the super 32 is a big tournament they
have they just have like big high school
tournaments and then in the off season
you have
like uh like Fargo tournaments you have
um now you have a like u17 and u20 world
team trials so those are very big so
it's basically just how you're doing
against these other guys in the High
School season in the off season and my
team was traveling everywhere so we'd be
in Ohio Wisconsin California Oklahoma
like we were wrestling all over the
country so you're winning these
tournaments yeah and that's why you're
number one in the country yeah coming
out of Texas yeah just you know most
it's just it's a small sport so you go
to a tournament like you're probably
gonna if you go to a big tournament like
let's say you go to big tournament in
Missouri and you get
50 teams there you're gonna get probably
one or two kids in your bracket that are
ranked right like you know just kind of
the way it works but yeah so you're
competing against these kids regularly a
lot of these kids I wrestled since I was
little right like Russell Demon's an
eight-year-old and I'm wrestling them in
college like that's not a uncommon thing
when does the recruiting process start
or when did it start for you I would say
right about then
um I was looking at schools kind of
trying to figure out where I wanted to
go my junior year
um we'd have college coaches you know
talking to me especially ones that were
close like Oklahoma Oklahoma State and
then schools that were maybe a little
smaller that wanted to like get in early
and try to
um
they just have to recruit differently
than a big school but it really started
heavy I would say
yeah like right after my junior year so
I committed to Penn State in between my
Junior and Senior year but really like
the end of my junior year it was like
heavy and like do they do they reach out
to you yeah so they'll send letters at
first maybe like request your
transcripts stuff like that but a lot of
times you know you're traveling to
tournaments and you just see guys there
you know like I said against a small
world so you just know coaches right
like when I was
probably fifth sixth grade we had my dad
brought coach Cale in for a clinic out
of high school so at this time he was
competing so like he
um but it was uh like like so we knew
him right like we've talked to him like
we see him at a tournament like we would
say hello you know like so a lot of the
coaches
they know me or they know my dad at
least so I can just text him you know I
don't know if that's illegal but
like Penn State didn't do that but of
course they didn't I'll say this
Penn State is so by the book it's insane
like every other school didn't really
like they were just basically hitting me
up message me on Twitter this and that
Penn State they started late and they
they came in at the very end
but you knew kale already yeah I
wouldn't say I we knew him like like I
said I'd done clinic and uh it wasn't
like I was friends with him or my dad
was friends with him but like we knew
each other and he was he's from Utah so
kind of like Utah Wyoming Colorado a lot
of those people know each other it's
just they they're wrestling the same
tournament stuff like that so was this
like the easy decision for you or was
there other schools that you thought
about there were a lot of other schools
so up until that point I had I took a
bunch of unofficial visits so I visited
University of Virginia I liked them a
lot I visited Nebraska Oklahoma State
um Ohio State basically what happened
was
um
I wrestled at a tournament in Ohio it
was the whatever u17 world team trials
and before the tournament I went to
Columbus and visited Ohio State and
met with the coaches and stuff and I was
like oh this is this is great I love
this place is awesome and they had been
in contact with me and stuff and they're
like all right full scholarship you're
set let's do it I'm like okay cool like
you know I want to visit Penn State as
well because I plan to visit Penn State
right after so I Wrestled a tournament
and then my dad and I drive to State
College visit Penn State
Vibe is so different but I love it
they're like so this is I just remember
this they just come everything with Ohio
state was
which I loved Ohio State but it was so
flashy like they took me to football
facilities I remember the quarterback it
was like JT Baird or something like that
he's throwing passes to receiver they're
like showing me like this is Big Time
this is cool and I'm like this is cool
wow it's incredible I get to Penn State
I go up into the coach's office it
office is like this big it's like normal
couches and they're like so what's up
like
you like wrestling I'm like I like
wrestling like do you guys like
wrestling like we're just like having
conversation they're just trying to get
to know me and stuff and very very
casual laid back and uh then I walked
around campus and stuff and I was like I
like these guys let's let's make it
let's figure this out every other school
at that point had been
100 your school's paid for you're good
to go and then Penn State I was like a
few weeks later
um my family was taking vacation to the
Cayman Islands we never took a family
vacation this is the first one we ever
took together because I was always
wrestling and they were like
I'm like I want to get this college
thing figured out before I go on seven
day vacation and don't have my phone and
stuff so I was just told the coaches I'm
like yo make me an offer like what are
you guys gonna do and they're like okay
here's what we can do we can do 50 your
first year because we have a big
recruiting class after that we'll give
you 100 so you're gonna have to come out
of pocket
uh out of state tuition 50 25 Grand
something like that and I was like
done let's do it I'll uh I'm ready and
uh
I called coach kale good with me I'm
coming to Penn State let's do it and
then uh
then I leave on vacation and uh somehow
the news got out a little bit I I told I
was like don't tell anybody like keep
this between us like don't say anything
and I don't think I don't know how it
got out coaches told somebody I don't
know but anyways I come back and they're
like a couple missed calls couple texts
follow what's up so then I have to call
every coach because I didn't want to
just now people just do announcement on
Twitter and then people figured out I
wanted to be like these coaches invest a
lot of time to me so I'm gonna call you
know John Smith I'm gonna call Tom
Brands I'm going to have a conversation
with these guys and let them know where
I'm going before it's tweeted alive
which was interesting that's what
happened yeah yeah it was it was the
right thing to do it was definitely not
fun but it was it wasn't that bad yeah I
was just like I only had one bad
experience
when you're you're in high school
you're kind of you're just dominating
but you're doing these other tournaments
did you start doing
did your dad did your coaches will you
started to do anything like from a
mental perspective to get ready to
compete
that's a great question
um in high school
I'm trying to think in high school it
was just all honestly
intuition off the cuff like
you know my dad I think was just a good
natural leader in that so the way he
would structure his practices is we'd
get our warm-up in he'd have everybody
kind of do like a team maybe some
push-ups some some like ABS type work
and then he would give everybody like a
quote of the day do like a quote of the
day kind of some type of mental
motivation or mental
um how to approach competition or
practice or Focus whatever that was it
was different every day and then so it
was something that was kind of talked
about
as uh in that sense but I didn't do
specific coaching to me until I got to
college and uh but but I felt like I had
a good base and understanding of
just kind of the the natural like mental
game of how to how to compete
but there were still a lot of things
that I think that were holding me back
when you were in high school and you
were getting ready to do your the finals
in the state tournament what was going
through your mind
10th grade 11th grade 12th grade yeah so
in high school
you know
I think that the main thing that I would
think about was
obviously winning and losing was on my
mind heavy but I would think like
just push that down just don't think
about it just go out there and send it
like just get after it like go out there
and freaking go for it and that that's
kind of was like my coping mechanism was
was I'm just gonna go for it like like
whatever like let's go let's do it like
I don't care like kind of just like
Cowboy Up like let's go and and that's
kind of was my only real mental
kind of
strategy for dealing with stress and
pressure and competition while I was in
high school which it would work out a
few times but not because not as
consistently as that would I would have
liked it to be yeah we we actually are
going to ask a question about this
handling stress and we did a podcast
about it and I for the first time in my
life
thought about what I did going into
stressful situations
and what I came up with was like
everything in the beginning was all like
oh yeah okay you're gonna practice
you're gonna prepare you're gonna
rehearse you're gonna do all these
things you're gonna think about how it's
going to go down I had all those things
but there's one thing that I've been
doing my whole life that I never really
thought about which is kind of very
similar to what you just said which is
basically
up until the execution I'm super humble
like I practice prepare plan think
through things rehearse again like all
that stuff that comes from humility and
then like when I put my night vision
goggles on
when I when I Lock and Load my weapon
I'm I'm like I'm gonna kill everybody
like I can't be stopped like we're gonna
crush the enemy so there's a level of
Cockiness that comes out of confidence
yeah just like okay we're I'm ready to
go and even if I'm
going to talk to a group of people like
I don't sit back you know backstage like
oh I hope I don't mess anything up no I
think like oh I'm gonna go you know
these people are gonna get their worlds
rocked right now let's go so it I had
this just was doing a archery up in up
in Montana and I was shooting with Leif
my buddy and I was shooting and because
we had done this podcast I had this
mindset and I was going up there and
we're doing the 3D archery shoot and
sort of freaking crazy targets you know
they're between trees and uphills
downhills where there was one of them
that was a a little white rabbit at 72
yards like these are hard freaking shots
to make and I for the first time ever I
went through the whole course with one
Arrow right which is hard to do is 25
shots one arrow and these are crazy
shots but I was talking to life and I
told him that I was like hey bro when I
walk up to that line I'm just like I'm
gonna freaking smoke this thing and
that's what happens you know you just
you just because if you're thinking like
oh I missed it open or Miss I hope I
don't hit that rock I open it at the
tree you guaranteed to hit that freaking
tree just call Timber before you shoot
you're gonna hit that tree
and so I think that's similar to what
you're saying and that the interesting
thing is that's kind of how you that's
how you wrestle like when people watch
you wrestle it's easy to see that you're
going I'm just gonna freaking get after
it I'm gonna send it yeah for sure you
know I think that I just always had that
that was naturally just me my
personality and it got kind of I guess
uh highlighted and and you know brought
even more to the to the front when I
would compete
but at the same time now I look back and
there were a lot of mental things that I
have added to my game and that I feel
like and things that I was also just
doing incorrectly like like just
different focuses that now I'm like I
had to let those go and I had to learn
lessons that basically brought me to
where I am now right like it's ever
evolving and I'm sure in 10 years when I
look back at where I am now and be like
dang that's what I was thinking when I
was prepared you know because that to me
that's the
biggest part of it right like and
everybody's gonna train hard everybody's
gonna have at what I'm doing they're
gonna have skills they're gonna have
certain things they're good at and you
know what's really going to separate
people
is mentally how
they're able to focus and be free and
and compete themselves like and be
themselves right like that that to me is
what I what I really try to focus on now
because like I said
every Pro MMA fighter or you know call
Dressler everybody's got reps dude
everybody's got reps you got to be elite
not only at that you got to have a
different part of your game that sets
you apart
just before we get into college when
you're growing up you're doing like
strength and conditioning with the
football team at Allen for those first
two years are you naturally strong are
you one of these people that's like like
look your dad played football in college
your mom played basketball college like
you have G you have good genes are you
abnormally strong so I was always I had
an interesting strength I was always
explosive and fast like I could shoot
very fast shots I could I could run
pretty quick I could change directions
fast but I was never a a strong guy a
guy that's going to grab you and you're
gonna be like whoa what the heck but I
was a guy like I could pick you up and
put you down fast but I had to work a
lot from all the way from high school
through college really and and still to
this day my my weaker points are like
that that brute strength right like
that's not really and I tailor my style
around that but I think you still have
to have some of that so that's what I
work on I work on the you know yeah
the squat the bench press the freaking
just like not to explode through
somebody but just like the grind
somebody down and that that's the that's
to me what doesn't come naturally so I
work on that a lot
so you show up you graduate state
champion
um you only got it four times
you know three oh wait oh that's right
because you're a freshman that's right
dang weak
I still I'm I feel like at this point
how many years later is that so 2010 so
13 years after I'm a little okay with it
like one percent I'm one percent okay
uh actually no that's not true
so three time state champion you
graduate finish your senior year you go
to Penn State
um
and you red shirt your first year
meaning you're there but you're not
participating you're not you're not
competing not competing on the uh
official team you know I'm competing uh
in open tournaments and stuff and and
training every day
and uh that was a very interesting time
it was really interesting I think back
about that time in my life a lot I think
I'm in a similar time right now with MMA
and getting into MMA so yeah yeah
interesting interesting stuff and and
you basically decide to do this because
it gives you another year to train learn
get stronger get more mature and and
that's what you do yeah how old are you
at this point like 19. I was 18. yeah so
I I was 18 yeah I um
basically for me the red shirt it made a
lot of sense for a lot of reasons I
needed to develop and get better
I was very raw naturally talented I had
some good fundamentals but overall
most of my wrestling was it was wild
gunsling and like you know and I would
come out on top most of the time but
there was a lot of risk and I needed to
develop a different side of my game and
uh so I was like you could put me out
there against anybody
even a guy way better than me and I got
a shot but that really wasn't what I was
looking to do I wasn't interested in
being a guy that has a chance to win I
was interested in being the guy that you
have no chance like to beat me that was
that was what so the red trigger made
sense
so you're working with kale
um
what are we calling him the greatest the
greatest Collegiate wrestler of all time
yeah I mean Collegiate that easily just
just unbelievable and like a presence
right and I've never met him but like
you can watch him and he just has a
presence
about him part of it's because he is the
greatest right but there's there's
another component there the thing you
can't really identify what's it like
with him for the first year what what's
that situation feel like so the
Situation's so interesting because like
I said he was my idol growing up it was
like the guy that I watched and he was
that guy I want to be and you know I
want to be a four-time undefeated
national champion because that's what he
did and you know that's something that
to me
for the first
while I'm just kind of watching him I'm
just like wow like what's up with this
guy like he's quiet he's very quiet and
this so he does individual meetings with
the guys
um at the beginning of the year
especially freshmen to kind of get a
read on him and I'm trying to figure him
out and this way does so I roll into his
office he's got like a big desk and uh
he sits back and he just goes like this
he's like kind of swiveling in his chair
and just staring at me and I'm like
we sat there for like 60 seconds and
nobody said anything which is a long
time like if you're yeah actually doing
it's a super awkward yeah and so he's
like like lean and I'm like
so what's up coach and uh cause I'm
waiting for him to say something and uh
but then yeah I don't really remember
the rest of the meeting I just remember
that but then I feel like he was trying
to figure me out but yeah and and I
think the first bit was just figuring
him out and being around him kind of
understanding what he thinks about what
he focuses on what he wants me to do
like what what do you expect of me coach
obviously expecting to win but how do I
get there and I think that first year
was
mostly learning through
absorbing it just being in in that
environment and just absorbing it and
seeing not only him but the rest of the
coaching staff the rest of the team how
they do things what they focus on what
what their mentality is like and uh
yeah I mean I tried to really
really like be present and be around him
and and really like
I was wrestling them a ton and just like
absorb everything that he was kind of
putting out but it was it was a big
learning curve because like I said I I
was very raw and had a lot of good
skills had a lot of success but had in
my mind you know just as many kind of
flaws in in my in my game and in my
mentality what's the
What's the culture how would you
describe the culture there this by the
way these oath Penn State right now
they're the they're the Kings right
what's their what's their record right
now past 10 15 years yeah I think we've
won we've won 10 out of the last 12
national titles and it's just insane
yeah yeah uh what's that what's driving
that what's the culture feel like yeah
so you know it's interesting because
everybody talks about how much we win
but we really never talk about winning
it's all about you know
the principles that the program are are
built on it's it's gratitude it's
knowing what you want it's
um taking care of each other and and
focusing on effort like really really at
the end of the day those are those are
the main things it's like effort
gratitude know what you want kind of in
that in in a different order though it's
know what you want it's effort it's
gratitude in in the correct order so
that's the things that that I was
learning and I think that they just take
things to it take things to a different
level as far as attention to detail
and
you being good at and proficient at
wrestling technically is definitely what
it's focused on most I think that they
obviously have a specific system and a
way they do things on the mat that's
very different I think they're 20 years
ahead of everybody else but in terms of
what technique or how they're drilling
or how they're everything everything I
think they're just they're just ahead
you know there's the head of the curve
and everybody tries to copy us with
whatever we do
and it just seems like
as far as
the types of techniques that they're
they're teaching
the way that they're they're teaching
them are very different the mentality is
very different behind
what to focus on when you're going out
to compete and also just the
different I don't know if amenities are
the right words but the different things
that they utilize to help us
be the best and make things easier on us
give me an amenity like uh hot and cold
tubs like like you know uh saunas stuff
like that like we our weight room it's
all right there
um but but I would say the biggest thing
like we have a full-time uh I don't know
if I would call our sports psychologist
because she's not she does more than
that but we've had a full-time basically
Sports psych for I don't know before any
team ever did that you know like the
coach kale was doing that when he was
competing and that was in two early
2000s and we've had one since 2009 2010
so that was just a standard like you met
with you met with Bonnie or ladies
Bonnie what what does she say to you
um kind of uh like what are you trying
to do what are you here for what do you
want you know like where did kale find
her so I think he was dealing with some
challenges mentally just being who he
was and wanting to win Olympic gold
medal and
um I I think he met her right after
college but they used to just uh do like
phone kind of consultations and she
would help him kind of get a grip on
everything that that he was trying to
accomplish and manage that and then when
he came to uh the head coaching position
at Penn State he brought her on staff so
she's been on staff with us you know
like I said before I even got there but
there was no schools doing that at all
like that wasn't even a thing and now
it's kind of like the standard but yeah
stuff like that and then you know we
utilized we have a great shrink
conditioning coach at Penn State but we
also utilize outside uh help for uh
shrink conditioning with the training
lab I don't know if you ever heard of
training lab but uh Sam calavita runs it
and so
he helps us he's easily the number one
shrink conditioning nutrition coach in
the world as far as Combat Sports go so
we've been utilizing him forever and uh
yeah and I think
the other cool thing is that our staff
coach kale his brother Cody
um
Casey Cunningham Jake Varner like
they've been with each other the entire
time like there they came to Penn State
together they're just the same guys so
they've and and if you look at their
daily meetings they have what their did
a year ago today what they did three
years ago today five years ago today a
decade ago today they know exactly what
it is so they have so much data and
information that they're just able to
help us
navigate a lot of or I guess they help
us not have to navigate a lot of stuff
that we maybe would have had to
otherwise
one of the things you said was they
that team and those coaches Focus they
they focus on the right thing like what
would you say they focus on that maybe
other wrestlers or other teams or other
people aren't focusing on you know
there's a lot I would say that the main
thing is we want to get better at
wrestling right like so what are you
going to do if you want to get better at
wrestling you gotta wrestle so that
that's what we're doing most the time
we're not yeah yeah we're gonna do our
conditioning workouts but we're not
going to put 100 miles on on we're not
cross-country Runners you know we're not
power lifters so we're going to focus on
what we want to do so I think that the
majority of what we do for obviously
technique and and for conditioning even
is wrestle so I wrestling more than
anybody else and then
they're focusing on our on our effort
and they're focusing on you know results
are important but that's a byproduct
right like we're gonna get the results
we want to get if we just do these
things you know so to me I think the
consistency that they preach that with
of is the same message right now than
what it was when I was a freshman the
way I was before that and and when you
can buy into that and and be consistent
with it that's how you're going to get
the results they're just going to come
you know you don't have to stress and
worry about it every day you just have
to
improve get better and when the moment
comes for you to make it happen you're
going to do it
when you say wrestle like when you say
we want to get good wrestling so we
wrestle how does that break down from
like a drilling versus live wrestling
like how does that break down
you know one one thing I think I will
say that is different about Penn State
as well is we have a system you know
there's a system of of moves and
techniques that we like to use that a
lot of the guys use
but they really do a great job of
tailoring everything individually to
people so
everybody's different right like some
guys they need a little more structure
they need all right I want you to drill
this 10 times once you drill this 10
times now do this 10 times and they need
that like me
you get me in there like show me some
some stuff and I'm gonna apply that
right away like you show me this
different technique that or this little
adjustment I should make
I don't even really need to draw like
I'm just gonna do it and you know it
helps to to drill it so I'll still do
some but
I think the ratio of of drilling to kind
of light sparring to live wrestling
is
adjustable for individuals which that
just takes effort so they're putting
more effort into doing that
um
spending time with guys who need more
time spending less time with guys who
maybe need less that are just flexible
and I think that most coaches it's like
get in that's what we're doing boom boom
boom boom done check check the list
we're out so it's a little bit more of
an open-minded attitude it's way more
open-minded and it's it's just what
makes sense it's like all right well
what makes sense for me at 197 pounds
isn't gonna be the same it was what
makes sense for 125 who is a freshman
who's 500 record like he needs something
different than me you know so that's
what they do they give them different
different
um I guess
kind of coaching how often
do you learn something new let's say
you're let's say you're let's go to your
freshman year yeah how often are you
kale or one of the other coaches going
like hey here's an actual new move for
you as opposed to like hey you can clean
up your double you can clean up this you
can clean up this
is there new moves that come in where
you're like yo I did not know that
because the crazy thing about Jiu Jitsu
is I've been training Jiu Jitsu for a
long time like a quarter century and
I've been we've been up here at this
camp and I learned like 20 new things
and so I'm talking things where I was
like oh I that's totally new to me I did
not know that and it's the same with you
know there's black belts here that have
been training for 30 35 years right and
they'll all be going oh I've never seen
that before yeah how much is there of
that when you were at Penn State a ton a
ton especially my my freshman year early
it was like I really learned a whole
different way to wrestle I was like I
think back about it
I was like I didn't even know how to
wrestle you know in high school I'm like
I'll watch film and I'm like what was I
doing and then my freshman year college
I still think that so I'm kind of doing
this little Series where I go back over
all my college wrestling matches and I
break them down it's so tough for me so
I'm just like
I suck so bad there's a freaking uh
video of me on the internet and I'm
competing against Jeff Monson and
grappling and it was like a 13-minute
match because it was Triple overtime
because it was zero zero okay triple
overtime the the thing on YouTube is cut
down to like two minutes and 30 seconds
and
and I watch it and I'm just absolutely
like humiliated and embarrassed because
I look so terrible I look so bad and I
mean I'm not actually human I'm like oh
you know that guy that guy's a good
wrestler a great Grappler he's an 80cc
world champion right and he's he had a
really incredible vitamin program that
he was on because he was completely
insane he jacked uh uh but a great
competitor but when I look at it I'm
like God I was terrible terrible that's
what I feel like so that's what you do
you're doing now just breaking stuff
down absolutely ridiculous yeah it's
insane and and so I think that
Combat Sports are so cool because you
can always do that you can always get
better even if you know
99 of everything there is to know you're
never gonna learn that one percent fully
you're gonna you know maybe creep up a
little bit a little bit a little bit and
uh you know it's for me it it I love
learning learning is one of the biggest
reasons that I got into MMA because
you know it's new I get to learn Jiu
Jitsu I get to learn Muay Thai I get to
learn boxing all this stuff like that's
so fun and exciting for me and that's
how I felt when I got to Penn State I
was like you know kind of come out of
high school I haven't lost in a while
I'm pretty good man and then
you get in and I was competitive right
away but
I wasn't trying to be competitive and so
I was like wow I need to learn how to
wrestle I need to learn how to wrestle
for real because I don't know so it you
I I wasn't really it's not that classic
scenario of oh you go and you get
whipped up and everybody's kicking your
butt and you can't score a point like I
was scoring and stuff was I beating the
best guys in the room no were they
whipping me a little bit Yeah but I was
scoring on on a lot of guys and doing
well
but I realized quick if I wanted to get
to where those guys were or where I
wanted to be
I needed to learn a lot about wrestling
uh so you get done your red shirt year
now you go into your I guess this would
be called your freshman year right yeah
2015 2016 or 174 pounds
um how's that season go so
when I look back on that season
um
it was just such a different
play I had to grow some I didn't I wish
I could have grown that much
in my Redshirt season because
I think as a red shirt you just don't
really know what that's like and and
then you get thrown into it a little bit
competing every weekend and and feeling
the pressure feeling 10 000 people in
the crowd and you know that's something
that
I just
think for the most part I
did the same thing that I'd always been
doing in high school I'm like let's just
go get it let's just throw down like I'm
ready to go and uh I was meeting with
our Sports Psych
every single week like you know trying
to figure myself out mentally trying to
figure out how I wanted to compete just
but I was doing all that
for the result I wanted the result I
wanted to be a national champion and and
that's not a bad thing but
that was what I was focused on whereas I
needed to learn just to let go of that
and just get better and improve and and
do my best and then the result will come
but all that year was so removed does
that somehow remove pressure I won't say
it removes pressure it just gives you a
different perspective of it because at
first it would be like so this is what I
was doing I was saying
to myself and my matches all right I'm
at the best program in the world I have
the best coaches and the best training
Partners in the world
and
these are all the reasons I should win
so I'm gonna go out there and compete in
this guy against this guy and I'm coping
and wrapping my head around what's about
to happen by telling myself I should win
because of these reasons when in reality
what I needed to be doing and what I
realized that I should be doing is
one the guy who's going to win isn't the
guy with
the best training Partners the guy that
um has the best coaches the guy that
works the hardest it's not the guy with
the most heart it's just the guy that
scores more points it's the guy that
gets his hand raised like is the guy
that wins the match like it's a it's a
match so that's what I'm trying to do it
doesn't have like none of this stuff
like yeah maybe it affects it
but that's not why the outcome happens
it's just who's course like okay I have
two points you have zero I win like
that's it and uh
so and and that's based on effort in
that moment and being present so you
know I think I would kind of just in my
mind not be very present and that's why
I got the results I did because in in
the NCAA finals I'm wrestling a guy so
yeah fast forward have a good year you
you start the season rank 14th I started
14 I start smoking guys I'm just better
than them and you know I I come in to a
little bit of a bump halfway through the
year I lose the kid from Indiana that
wasn't nearly as good as me but I had a
bad match I'm a freshman devastated me
now I can't be undefeated what am I
going to cry about it no I still got big
tens NCAA so I just move on and uh
Big Ten Tournament crush it kill it
ncaas
I'm feeling it I'm like number one seed
I'm a freshman
this Madison Square Garden is a big deal
like like and in my mind the coping
mechanism was every match
I should win because I have better this
and that and then I get to the finals
against a guy who I've wrestled at this
point probably five times
[Music]
Big Ten Tournament two weeks earlier
first period throw them down easy money
and uh I go on to the match
and that that's what I'm thinking I'm
thinking all right I got I work harder
than this dude I know I'm more
disciplined than him I just beat him I
just beat him stuck him he penned him
and killed him like never have even been
really competitive with this guy I have
better coaches better training Partners
like more fans want me to win like I can
make every up make up every excuse in
the book I'm like giving myself excuses
to win and uh
so then you know wrestle the match and
there's there's a big moment in the
match so right away I go for the crazy
throw he takes me down and uh which I'm
like whatever I don't care we'll get up
and and then and me in my mind it was
like
almost back to what I was saying earlier
about in high school I would go out to
just like let's get it I'm gonna go For
Broke when I I didn't really have to
almost as like a
just an another excuse like I'm just
going for it like I'm gonna I'm gonna go
for I'm gonna give up like but I really
wasn't going to
to win it was it was a weird mental
thing and so get taken down I come back
up take him down
and now I'm rolling so I'm like all
right I'm about to win this match like
no doubt I have an underhook I'm going
far knee pick and we're going out of
bounds and
I'm running through them and I'm like oh
I'm about to freaking crush this dude
plant them on the mat get a takedown
probably get an ear fall and seal the
seal this up and
for some reason you know I just get my
arm trapped boom rolled through right
onto my back and I'm just like what is
going on what just happened it was the
only time I've ever wrestled
in a match and not really been super
aware and known what is going on and
like been like known how much time's
left known where I'm at on the mat it
like just completely
this this I was in disarray and uh
I get off the mat was it like
overconfidence in that moment I think it
was just
not being present I think it was
either it was I was either in the in the
past or in the future I wasn't in that
moment either already the champ or I
already worked harder yeah yeah I wasn't
locked in to like get it done right here
you know this all that matters is right
now it was it was I was just not there
and so boom rolled through and I get up
and I'm like
almost almost like literally dizzy and
uh
then but and I don't even know how much
time is left on the map so where I lost
this match it wasn't even in getting
thrown
I go back down
and then there was whatever 20 seconds
left in the period And I get wrote out
if I just got an Escape right there I
guarantee I win the match even though I
was losing at that point ten to four or
something like that I think and uh so I
end up losing
um I I come back the guys runs for me
the whole third period but I just can't
get to him I lose 11 to 9. I had no idea
what the score was at the time I had 15
seconds all I needed was one takedown
and I could have tied it up and uh it
was just I just didn't know where I was
at I couldn't wrap my head back so
that was you know I said my freshman
year of high school was devastating this
was like 10 times that because I'm in
front of this huge crowd it's this it's
really my biggest goal right this is
what I've been thinking about as my
biggest goal it's four-time National
Champion and uh
if I don't win my first one it's done
it's like I got three more years but
it's done and so there was legitimate
probably three months of of real
depression after that where in my head I
just I just didn't know what to do I'm
like
what is the point of this I freaking
went to a sports psych for 40 weeks in a
row all to get second like well that was
stupid waste of time how dumb was that
and uh you know put all this effort in I
you know wrestled for 15 years to go out
and beat get beat by this guy like what
is wrong with me and just very very
negative very like depressed and
just kind of like don't want to do
anything sitting in bed like I would
have
this was the worst is I would have
dreams where
or I would have a nightmare where like I
would lose like what would happen in
real life happened what was worse was I
would have dreams where I won oh it
would be like I would be dreaming and
I'd be like oh I won the match I'd wake
up and I'd be like I would just like
start crying I almost cry right now
think about it but yeah it was like uh
it was terrible so I'd have to wake up
to this reality of uh you know all right
yeah I lost and I got to
probably end of July early August and I
just remember one day being like in
waking up and just being like
are you gonna cry about this for the
rest of your freaking life you're gonna
be a wimp are you gonna are you gonna
quit you're just gonna like be done like
that's it and then I was like hell no I
ain't doing that like let's let's get
back on the horse so
then I have to reset
and I'm thinking what is the what can I
do
to kind of make up for this what can I
do to like make over this and so I'm
thinking
all right well
184 which is the way about me is the
toughest way in the country
and
not only is it the toughest weight as
far as depth but it's got the number one
pound per pound guy in the country Gabe
Dean from Cornell at this weight
I was like I need to reset recharge
myself I'm going to 184. and I'm winning
I'm winning that like I'm that's what
I'm doing and so now was
I wouldn't even say
solve what was going on with me
internally it was
reassess create a new goal and now just
chase that and kind of just let that
fill in this void that had been left in
me yeah you needed a new Mission I need
a new Mission because I didn't I was
lost I didn't know what to do and uh
I I had no motivation for like I was
like what's gonna what's gonna get me
excited to compete again and so it was
this it was like this this big challenge
of beating the number one pound for
pound guy in the country and winning the
toughest weight in the country like
that's what I had to do and how'd your
coaches feel about this what did kale
say to that so I told him I was like
coach I'm going up to 84. and he was
like
um I think we want you at 74. um so why
don't you know you certify at 74. and I
was like
we'll see I certified 184.0 I was like
there I'm not giving you guys one
tread of uh hope that I'm going 174 this
year because I'm I'm committed to this
I'm all in because we did have a really
good guy at 184 who's a good friend of
mine and uh I was like this is gonna
work itself out but I I'm a team guy
like we had we had won the team National
Title at my freshman year that was very
important to me we had you know and so
but I was like I see it from a different
perspective as you you know we have a
couple good guys coming in at 74. my guy
84 he can move up to 97. this is gonna
be good and I'm gonna kill it so as long
as I win everything else is gonna work
out what do you walk around at that
point so at that point I probably walked
around at 184. sure yeah so I cut a
little weight my freshman year
um I was a little lighter I was probably
180 but yeah I was weighing about 184
185. do you change anything in the way
you were training
uh going up well not just going up but
now that you had this loss you had this
new goal where you going harder or were
you working harder you step up your game
I always worked you know basically did
everything I could I was always super
intrinsically motivated
but I think that my mindset changed from
being like a
you know more wild type of competitor
try to try to throw you big moves to
just
I need to dominate these guys I need to
get consistent I need to get
my main focus that summer was get an
attack
like a leg attack that's consistent that
nobody could stop because I didn't
really have that up at that point I had
a lot of tricks I had a lot of sneaky
stuff and that really got me to where I
was but I was like I needed one go-to
that nobody in the world could stop and
you know a lot of people say that about
different stuff like what's your thing
that nobody can nobody can defend and so
that's what I worked on it was righty
caller tie Lefty high C the whole summer
I probably drilled it
I drilled it 90 of my drills was that
yeah yeah
uh so then that season starts and you
you crush yeah I'm crushing it I'm like
knocking it out of the park right
um I think my first seven or eight
matches I pinned every single guy I was
like on a roll
um a couple big moments I'm wrestling uh
my first match in Carver Hawkeye Arena
and I'm wrestling Sammy Brooks so this
is kind of funny I uh
a couple I gotta say a couple
pre-stories before I say get into the
match but
back to when I was getting recruited
um and I I committed to Penn State I had
to call all the coaches I call Tom
Brands right and uh I'm like hey coach I
just want to let you know and that I'm
gonna be committing to Penn State I
didn't want you to see it on Twitter or
something I wanted to tell you uh you
know myself and he's like okay well you
know appreciate it thank you for for
doing that
um
are you sure like this where you want to
go and stuff I'm like yeah I'm sure I'm
sure he's like okay okay that's fine you
know as long as you're not competing
against the Hawks we'll be rooting for
you but we'll see you on the mats I just
remember you said we'll see you on the
mats and I was like
see you on the mats and then I roll into
Carver it's insane they're yelling crazy
stuff at me you know the fans are going
nuts they're throwing trash it's like
wild it's like what is going on this is
ridiculous you're going down mother
effort like get ready to freaking get
smoked like let's go like like obviously
I'm not cursing but they're cursing and
stuff and uh so I walk out and the fires
go they got like flamethrowers it's
insane and I get on the mat and I'm like
seeing you on the mat so we're here
let's do it and uh but I'm sorry I
missed I missed the I had to say one
other thing so I'm wrestling Sammy
Brooks so he was I think Big Ten
Champion it was maybe number I think I
was number two in the country he was
number he was top five maybe three or
four and uh
I don't know why but I didn't really cut
weight like I said
for some reason the night before that
match I just randomly was the heaviest
I'd ever been in my entire life I was
like 192. I was like it was something
weird with the travel and I had a
smoothie at Smoothie King in the Chicago
airport and I think it did it and I was
like what is going on I've never I had
to work out like two or three extra
times and so
going in the match I'm like
these guys are all yelling how they're
going to get me tired I was like I
better not get tired like this is not
gonna be good
um and and right before that are we they
know you were off wait they didn't know
that nobody knew no no my coach sitting
there yeah I didn't tell anybody I just
did it but uh so we we took our we had a
kid a true freshman his name is Mark
Hall he was like the number one recruit
in the country come out of high school
we pulled his red shirt in the in the
match before like his first Varsity
match and uh he lost he got upset and it
was crazy it was like the crowd was
going it was the decision to pull his
red shirt so they had somebody got hurt
or something they had been talking about
it the whole year but basically the team
Race was pretty tight and uh they kind
of and Mark wrestled at the Southern
Scuffle which is like kind of the
Premier Tournament of the mid-season
anyone and he beat all the starters from
the other schools and so they're like
this might be a good option like we
might do it we might need to let him let
our horses run and so boom pull the red
shirt
boom loses and then they're like at
their all-time peak of excitement as
Iowa fans because the duel is I think
they're up maybe like 1816 something
like that and uh we have our our next
three matches are all kind of toss-ups
because me and Sammy are top five the
next two guys are like top top 10 guys
and our heavyweight's a toss-up match
and uh so they're thinking like we're
gonna win all three of these we got
momentum let's go
I'm like all right bro I'm gonna show
you something real quick so I just knew
I knew the way he wrestled Sammy Brooks
he's so aggressive like dude this dude
can't not shoot on me like he's gonna
shoot on me I'm gonna freaking stick him
in something and especially there in
front of that crowd everyone I'm like
this dude's coming in hot like I'm I'm
like that's perfect for my style my
style is great if you attack me
forget about it you're not gonna beat me
you gotta you gotta play it smart play
it safe and try to sneak one in on me
like that's that's was really people's
only chance to to get me and so
um
boom single leg right away beautiful
single leg in my mind I'm thinking dang
that was a nice shot whatever let's go
and so he just makes a mistake steps his
leg up wrong boom catch him pin him
splatable it was crazy everybody I'm
going nuts the crowd all of a sudden
silent I give him a little bit I'm like
what's up y'all and then and then Coach
kill goes hey knock that off like he's
yelling at me
okay whatever let's get off the mat and
so just this crazy Whirlwind coach kale
don't play that kind of yeah he don't
play that no so got that win big win for
me and uh now you know we we kind of go
me and me and this dude Gabe Dean from
Cornell are like on a tear towards each
other I go into the Big Ten Tournament
rated number one number one and I'm like
I I think that I wrestled maybe 20
matches 20 22 matches and I've had like
17 pins it's like crazy like I'm pinning
everybody and like I pinned Sammy Brooks
I pinned the Oklahoma State kid I
probably pinned like three or four top
five guys
and so going in the big tens I'm feeling
confident I'm like all right let's go I
have a buy I'm in the quarters and then
boom I have to wrestle
the Ohio State kid who beat me the year
before I wrestled him in the duel
earlier and and beat him up eight to two
or something and so I'm feeling good and
uh not really nervous at all
and uh we go in and we're wrestling and
I take him down right away and I'm like
all right I kind of got this unlock and
uh boom he takes me down and then it's
tied and I'm like okay like this a
little more competitive and he shoots in
on my my leg
and I freaking like my LCL just boom
pops and I'm like what the hell was that
I don't even know what that was but
whatever like let's keep going I like
just kind of struggling and then the
match just it was a weird match just
gets away from me and he and he get and
I can't and I don't take him down he
beats me five to four and I'm like what
just happened like
I don't know I just lost like that's
crazy and I remember going off the mat
and and it was weird because what
tournament was that this is the big tens
it's like in the quarterfinals the big
tens and it was just kind of unexpected
and I wasn't really that nervous for the
match and after I lost
I felt so weird I was like
I just was like it wasn't upsetting like
my other losses it was like uh
I just couldn't really I just felt like
I didn't know what hap I just didn't
know why I lost and I was like all right
well
I'm just gonna move on I guess I don't
know it was I've never felt like that
after I lost
and so go the rest of the tournament I
take third he's wrestling the kid from
Iowa in the finals he loses
and he goes in the back I just remember
this so vividly he goes in the back and
he's like yelling like screaming so
pissed and I just remember feeling like
all right I need to figure out how to
like I'm not gonna deal with losses like
that anymore like I'm not that's not
really what I'm gonna do and
I was like kind of finding myself also
with my faith at this time and you know
my faith was always something that's
very important growing up and something
that I really tapped into a lot but I
was really learning a lot about it in
this in this kind of time period of my
life as well I was having Bible studies
with some close friends and really
diving into what that meant to me and
just kind of thinking about life on a
bigger level outside of wrestling and so
um actually my third fourth match
I was wrestling to do for Nebraska and I
hit him in like a sick uh like a judo
throw and I completely tear my LCL like
my knee is like this and it goes for
like my knees here my foot's here and it
just goes
I'll show you a video after it's awful
but tear my LCL completely I can barely
walk and uh but I I won and I got third
and so now I'm thinking I'm like how am
I gonna get ready for the NCAA
tournament
like I still gotta go win like I'm not
really okay I lost cool move on whatever
and uh
I I still got the ends I think that's
why maybe I was able to refocus because
I still was had this goal of being NCAA
champion and you know it I was like I
can still do this so I take the two
weeks my I'm not really training I can't
really train at all I'm just doing rehab
and then we get to the tournament
and uh
I just felt like
through all the growth that I've done in
my faith and all the growth that I was
doing just in myself personally at just
a great place mentally and not feeling
pressure on myself the way I was before
and I didn't really know why 100 of that
moment but first round boom Tech Fall
second round I'm wrestling uh the kid
from Nebraska who I wrestled at the big
tens he was n Save finalists multiple
American pin him semifinals or wait no
no second round sorry I wrestled
Binghamton pinned him third round at
Russell Nebraska pin him fourth round
I'm wrestling the Iowa kid that I pinned
earlier in the year and I just knew I
was like dude this guy is good he's not
gonna be able to stay out of his back I
just know it 60 seconds boom pin him so
I went Tech pin pin pin to the finals
and I'm just killing it I'm like yeah
I'm not losing there's your chance so
confident watching at the same time I
had four other teammates make the finals
all in a row so 49 57 65 74 than me
there's only been up to this point
three teams to ever have five guys in
the finals and we were we were the third
and I'm watching Gabe Dean Russell and
he's having like tight match here tight
match there semis is kind of close and
I'm like yeah I got this dude like
you're done bro so the entire year I'm
visual I always visualize myself and
Gabe Dean wrestling last match so I knew
it was going to be boom he's the senior
I'm like pretty hyped up so they're
gonna make this the last match of the of
the night and I would do this because
my buddy who laughs at this story
because uh me and me and my best friend
Tony he was on the team as well we would
be walking back to the parking lot and
it was like probably a maybe a little
over a quarter mile to our car from from
wrestling and I would always hand in my
backpack didn't matter I'll be like in
jeans and boots or whatever be snowing
and I would just dead Sprint like all
the way to the car and I'll come back
and get him and he didn't know why but
the whole year I would do this it would
just be in my mind I'd be like Gabe Dina
ain't doing this like I'd finish the
whole practice and then just like I
don't know it was just something dumb
but in my mind now I get to this point
and uh so they boom they start at 197
they're finishing 84 with us and uh so
I'm just thinking
all right uh
I'm just you know very clear in my mind
what I'm gonna do everything's good we
get to 149 boom Zane wrath kills it one
wins 157 boom Jason off kills it wins 65
Vincenzo Joseph big matches wrestling
Isaiah Martinez
insane upset he'd lost to him a couple
times wins I'm like what the hell we're
three for three let's go 74 so I'm on
Deck Mark Hall our guy that we pulled
red shirt he's in the finals against
Ohio State kid who beat him in the big
tens a couple weeks earlier crazy match
boom wins four in a row and I'm like
guys I got this like it's over like
don't it was the only match I've ever
had
only wrestling match I've ever had were
a bad thought a negative thought could
not creep and penetrate my mind there
was never a oh what if I lose or oh what
if this happens like you know every time
you compete something like that comes in
your mind but
it was so sound and so clear to me
because of how much visualization I did
and how
just
I knew what was going to happen and
I didn't know how it was going to happen
but I just knew I was going to win and
so boom go out of the match takes me
down and I'm like what the hell but in
my mind I was just like that was a great
shot like I couldn't do anything about
that whatever get up there's you know a
minute left in the period I get away
right away and then I think all right
let's just get one on this guy so boom
take him take him down kind of a weird
little I shot a single leg which is not
really to the left it was just not
really a shot I hit but I just pulled in
and finished it because I don't know
I've never even done that ever like in a
match before I just did it and then say
finals because I felt like it but uh
take him down and then there's 30
seconds left in the period and I'm like
all right I gotta ride the suit out so
ride them out go into the second period
three two and I'm like it's over you're
he's not gonna he's not gonna beat me so
get to the last 30 seconds
he shoots in on my leg gets in deep this
is the second period this is third
period so the second period I think he
got an escape third period I got an
escape something like that and so I'm up
4-3 20 30 seconds left shoots in on my
leg
and I watched back on video and I'm like
oh that was like kind of close but I'm
just scrambled and I was just so calm I
was like he's not taking me down no shot
but boom I uh I'm scrambling he kind of
gets in the position I roll I look up in
the clock and I got both his ankles he's
got both my ankles and it's just like
four seconds and I'm like four seconds
and it's like three
two one boom match over and I'm like
I'm the champ I did it I did it like
that's it like let's go like that's
crazy so go hug my coaches like not even
really a big celebration I was like wow
like that's crazy go hug the coaches and
um
it feels amazing right like it feels
great and uh then what was so
interesting to me about this whole
process is I felt like finally that
wrong from last year was righted like I
I made it right and and we're all good
now and then
like a couple days later I was like oh I
don't really care like it's over like
that was cool that I did that I'm glad I
did it but
what's next you know and and what it
really taught me
it taught me that
I cannot be so result oriented I can't I
it's okay to care about the outcome have
goals things like that that's all you
have to right but my identity and my
Foundation can't lie in results because
the feeling of winning Fades so fast the
feeling of losing Fades albeit slower
but but those are just feelings that
they're gonna fade and so why would I
wrap up so much of my self-worth in that
and then it was like
boom switch flipped
in my mind of what I need to focus on in
in competing and how I need to approach
my sport
and uh
after that it was like I had so much fun
because before I was having some fun but
it was more stressful than fun after
that it was like
this is this is good so are you like now
since you're not focused on the results
it's the summer time it's the fall
you're starting to season you're just in
practice does this mean every practice
you're like you're just focused on
effort and working in this particular
practice that I'm in right now so for me
the effort and the work was never an
issue that was never something where I
was like needed motivation to work hard
I was always the guy that was gonna
go 100 like there was never a situation
where that wasn't going to happen so for
me it was more just relax have some fun
like let's enjoy this if I'm I I'm
choosing to do all this
so let's have fun let's let's smile
let's like have a good time and and even
if I'm in a grueling workout even if I'm
doing something where we're going a 45
minute go and I'm wrestling coach kale
and we're we're at each other
it's okay like let's smile let's be like
yeah let's go and I also think that what
helped me too was I was
compartmentalizing my life a bit with my
relationship with God and my faith and
it was like that's what I would do on
Sundays and Wednesdays and you know I'd
pray before meals but like that was that
and and I realized I was like okay if
this is my life and if my faith is as
important to me as it is
let's see what happens when I invite God
into my wrestling because I wanted to
control that I was like
I'm in control of this wrestling stuff
but what if I was like all right God
I'm in the middle of practice and it's
me and you here like thank you like like
kind of you know praise him a little bit
thank him a little bit for for in those
moments and and that's what kind of I do
now continuously is like I don't ever
feel like
I have compartments of my life where all
right this is business this is wrestling
or this is fighting and this is my faith
and this is my family it's like I'm just
the same person all the time and
my my values and character that I take
into one I take into the next and that
really
relieved a lot of stress from me and it
made everything way more fun
yeah so it sounds like it's more of
enjoying the process and not thinking I
have to do this because I want that it's
I get to do this and that other thing
will come for sure it's all gratitude
it's all you know found founded on that
kind of just being grateful for
everything that I have and then
just enjoying it having fun smiling
because
I could do anything I want to do so if I
choose to do this I'm gonna have a good
time I'm not gonna
dreaded or hate it or be fearful
um even that's and that's how I feel
like I've carried that same mentality
into the rest of my wrestling career
into my fights it's all
you know I'm doing this because I want
to do it so let's have a good time and
but it's not that so it keeps that that
fun kind of free spirit but I'm also not
at that point where I use it as an
excuse you know what like what I did
when as a kid like I'm just gonna go for
it and see what happens it's like no you
know that's not really it either it's
it's not all it's all fun like like I'm
here to win like there's no doubt about
that like when it's time to compete we
can get down and it can get serious real
quick but that doesn't mean that I'm not
enjoying it if that makes sense yeah
because you could also take that to
practice too where like oh this isn't
really fun I don't want to do another
few rounds yeah like that's not fun for
me so I'm gonna go uh stop practice it's
not like that like I the fun for me is
doing things that other people aren't
willing to do like I'm gonna do
everything that you're not willing to do
and then the results will speak for
themselves and uh I just like pushing
myself too like it's just fun to to push
myself and do things that are really
freaking difficult I feel like if you're
not struggling if you're not doing
struggling in life in some way
like what are you doing you want to just
sit on the couch and eat Cheetos and
everything's plush and comfy like that's
not real so I don't know that's to me I
I want to like live real life
so you roll into your next season it's
2017 2018 you're still at 184 pounds and
you're just kind of crushing now yeah so
I'm crushing on a roll I wrestled the
the my little arrival from Ohio State a
few times whipped him and uh really the
whole story of that year it wasn't me it
was the teams Ohio state had a stack
team so they got a couple transfers in
in addition to the guys they already had
and in reality if you look at it it was
the greatest team Race
ever in NCAA Wrestling history just with
the guys that they had the guys that we
had and uh two big moments really stand
out that we had to do with Ohio State
people call it like dual it was a duel
of the century and at Rec Hall
6 500 people sold out
it was insane and Ohio State we do the
you know
handshake before the match and stuff and
they roll out they're all wearing these
bright red robes and they're got their
their Hood up and they're standing in a
like a one by one on the end of the mat
and it's like this sea of white and blue
and then these 10 guys in like red robes
and we walk out and I just remember
being like
at this point you know good place
mentally on our team is very tight very
close and I'm like well that's what
these guys like are they for real
because like our thing is we huddle up
before each of us go to face off and
we're like grabbing each other like all
right brother let's go let's get it
let's have some fun and like little one
guy's like just get massaged and they're
like all right then he sends out and
then he'll shake hands and you go in
order 25 33 41 blah blah and uh
they're like
I'm like all right bro chill like it's
not that big a deal but what had
happened two weeks earlier that made it
competitive was our 157 pounder who is
no Jason he tours PCL so he was not
competing at that point we thought he
was maybe going to be done for the
season and so
we're like all right that's like a
10-point swing right there he's probably
gonna get a pin now he got to throw it
back up and he's probably gonna lose
major decision so that's not good but uh
anyway so the duel's going we're kind of
getting beat up like at the beginning
we're getting beat up we lose the close
matches and then uh
it comes to Mark uh the guy that was the
way below me he wins so we got a low
momentum now we're like all right let's
go and uh then I come up and I'm
wrestling miles and uh
first minute of the or not first two
minutes of the match we're getting like
a crazy scramble he almost takes me down
but then I just get out of it and I
freaking get him I take him down I'm
like all right nice I know if I get the
first takedown on this dude like he he
breaks like I'm gonna get him the longer
the match goes if it's close I'm gonna
win if I'm winning obviously then it's
gonna spread the Gap but so I get that
on him and then uh
so I'm winning the match pretty
comfortably I think I'm up eight to two
there's 20 seconds left and I'm on top
I'm just holding him down everybody's
cheering and I'm like oh dang or no no
I'm up I'm up seven to two but I have a
riding time point so I'm like if I get a
turn here I can uh
I can get the major decision get an
extra point and so
I just think in my mind I was like who's
the best guy and this is all happening
in like a split second I was like who's
the best guy I know on top oh it's Zayn
what would Zane do and Zan's bow and
arrow guy so he gets a freaking so I I
look back his ankle's just sitting there
boom grab a bow and arrow put him on his
back as time's expiring it's like three
two one the guy's like one two get my
two near fall boom goes up on the board
I'm like oh crap let's go made a
decision and uh got the extra point for
my team so now I'm like fired up I'm
like let's go let's get it and then the
next match 197 they got the number one
kid in the country right Colin Moore and
our guy uh is my best friend his best
man in my wedding I'm gonna be best man
his wedding in a couple months Anthony
casar he had just lost a wrestle off to
another one of our teammates on Monday
but our other teammate got hurt so he's
kind of like the back of it at this
point but I know Anthony I'm like yo
this dude's a freaking like he can win
and uh it's a great matchup so but
nobody knows this besides honestly
probably me and him like even our
coaches I don't even know if they
thought he could win but he goes out
and uh literally the entire time
everybody's like on their feet and uh
first periods like zero zero boom gets a
takedown and then second period uh it's
like three two short time left and then
uh Colin Moore like gets into you on a
shot Anthony like belly whizzers him
spins around him boom takes him down
again he's up five two it's like 20
seconds left and everybody's freaking
out like no he's got it and so boom wins
the match crazy selly everybody's losing
their minds we're up 19 to I think it's
19 to 14 or 19 to 15 yeah 19 to 14. so
heavyweight comes now we got Nick
Neville too good wrestler couple time
All-American they come out with Kyle
freaking Snyder who's one of my best
friends but obviously enemy at this
point Kyle freaking Snyder Olympic gold
medalist multiple time world champion
NCAA freaking Dominator
like I'm like crap like he's Tech fault
Nick multiple times like but he he has
to pin him or Tech him for us to for
them to win and uh
Kyle I love him I love him if he trains
with us now in any line wrestling club
um he's living he came to the the good
side but
uh he was like talking mad trash before
this match like this whole year like he
was saying stuff there's no team on
Earth I would rather beat than Penn
State we're coming for you guys y'all
best be ready he posted like some uh
like Tombstone Clips like I'm coming
hell's coming with me that type of stuff
and I'm like all right Kyle time to get
time to get it like let's see what you
got you got a pen or a Pinner boy but so
we'll see so right away
and and Kyle's like a dude high energy
just a tank comes out he's getting after
it boom our dude single legs him takes
him down Crowd Goes Nuts everybody's oh
my gosh what's going on he just tucked
out all of the gold medalist what's
going on Boom Cal gets away starts
taking our guy down and I'm like oh
frick
come on so he's probably up six to two
six to four or something like that
second period and uh
then he gets a little crazy and and he's
small like he's 230ish our guy's like a
265 heavyweight and uh he goes for a
lateral drop boom Falls right on his
back
Neville's lands on him takes him down
and then everybody's freaking out again
oh my gosh and now he's like making Kyle
work to get up he's got a lot of weight
on him so he starts getting a little
tired but then uh he kind of gets back
on it starts racking up points racking
up takedowns and uh
so now that we're just counting down the
second second periods and we got two
minutes you just gotta like and it's
somewhat tight of a match it's ten to
six something so as long as it doesn't
get blown out as long as it doesn't get
blown out he's only got two minutes to
do it so we're like watching oh Kyle's
shooting going so crazy trying to take
him down take him down seconds or taking
seconds or taking seconds or taking he's
racked up a few takedowns it's 14 to 8
or something and uh there's like 30
seconds left and he gets in on the leg
and he's like trying to take him down
try and take him down and our guys like
defend and defend and on his feet boom
sprawls on him big sprawl everybody's
freaks out there's still 20 seconds left
but we know now it's like it's done it's
over if he's not gonna get it and it was
just the craziest duel ever you know we
win people are like crying in the stands
like like moms are just like holding
their babies in there like it's just
insane it's like what's we're just
jumping up and down the me and the line
the nitty line the mascot are just
hugging each other like let's go go on
like just freaking out going insane so
we beat these dudes and and then uh
do the big Zen tournament National
tournaments come in now this is like
freaking big deal and and we didn't
really match up that well in the in the
team Race because they had 10 top to
bottom like beasts and we were like kind
of a little top heavy we had a lot of
good guys um like like finalists
Champion type guys but our depth wasn't
there and so
basically we uh
we're in like a super tight team Race we
get to the finals we have
we have do we have we have four in the
finals I think it's me Mark zaneoff
no we have five in the finals again no
yeah yeah we have five again in the
finals so we gotta win we have to win
three of these matches and
um I have to win because I'm wrestling
boom my rival again Ohio State and they
they made uh Snyder the last match so it
was his senior year heavyweight and uh
so he could kind of go out
um on his him as last match and he's
wrestling a big uh uh rival to it from
Michigan but
basically the way it'll go down is
if Ohio State win Kyle's gonna win so if
if it's going to come down to my match
so we win our our first two and then
lose lose at 65.74 so now it's me and
miles and it's like
this is for the national championship as
a team like this whole year is like
coming down to this match and uh
I'm freaking
nervous I'm like I hadn't really felt
this a lot but this whole tournament
for some reason I got so caught up in
the team team part of it I wasn't
wrestling well and uh
if I would have just went out and pinned
a couple guys like we would have had it
already locked up but I didn't freaking
I was watching like all of every single
guy of ours wrestling every single guy
theirs so I got so wrapped up in this
team Race my coaches kept having to like
pull me pull me back off the floor go
sit down like yelling at me and stuff
and I'm like oh like I want it so bad
for for the team and uh because to me it
was always like a personal thing me
winning versus other guys
but when I started to it got so tribal
with the team stuff like
like them them saying stuff about us and
you know they were just so different
than us and you know of course
everybody's a wrestler so they're kind
of same but they were so outspoken and
we're very reserved and I just wanted to
shut them up so bad and I wanted my I
wanted my boys to feel that I wanted all
of Penn State all of like the the nitty
Line Community to like feel that and so
now I'm like we're here like I gotta
show out I gotta do this I'm like Frick
sitting down and uh trying to you know
all right man just let's enjoy this
let's have some fun let's be present
like this type of thing like like all
right just don't lose yeah then I'm like
dude but if you lose this is gonna be a
freaking this is where it's gonna be
terrible thoughts are creepy exactly
yeah and so the negative thoughts were
kind of creeping and um there was this
one moment where coach kale comes up to
me and he's like hey I'm like what's up
he goes I just want to let you know if I
had to pick anybody to go out there in
this match I'd pick you and I was like
well hell yeah let's go let's do it then
and that just like got me right back to
where I needed to be so we go out and uh
right away I'm like this dude had crazy
energy he was ready to go he came with
you know he was coming with everything
so he shoots a hard double Lake I kind
of get my foot caught in the mat and
like we fall out of bounds I'm like all
right whatever let's go let's have some
fun so now we're moving we're moving and
he shoots it on my uh leg with like a
minute left in the first period And I
easily could have just sprawled and and
and and uh defended it and got him off
but I kind of had an underhook and it
had his neck a little bit and I was like
I was not scared at all it wasn't like a
fearful thing like what I was kind of
saying earlier about going for it but I
was like
I think I got this so boom I go to throm
and uh he kind of sprawls his hips back
and I'm like oh crap whatever all right
no worries I just like the Situation's
happening so fast I just kind of turned
down
he immediately drives back into me to
try to take me to my back and then I'm
like big mistake Bud boom flip him over
land on top and as soon as that happened
it was like
matches over dude you're done so I just
I got him get on top get the pin and
immediately after you get the pin I'm
just like
get to your coaches you got to celebrate
this so hard so I me and my first coach
coach Casey we run and he's like a
little smaller so I grab him boom pick
him up I'm like let's go come on and
then I go to grab Coach Kayla I'm going
to do the same thing and as soon as I'm
reaching for him he just goes boom drops
down below me and I'm like what's
happening and then double like picks me
up and I'm like this it's like Titanic
and I'm just like let's go and we're
just all freaking out and uh you know
won the match and you know I go the
coolest thing I go off the map
and my buddy who I was saying Mark who
was away below me he's the first one
there he just lost the NCAA finals match
before first one there let's go like
celebrate and congratulate me and I was
like dude that's so freaking cool like
you're such a good dude for that he
easily could have been in the back like
just pissed but he was the first one
that I saw coming off the mat and that
meant a lot to me but then uh
I'm like freaking out we're going nuts
and Coach kale is like hey you need to
calm down you're about to do an
interview with ESPN and I'm like okay I
got it coach I'm chill
put the mic on my on me he asked
questions blackout I have no idea what I
said so I black out I'm like whatever
let's go boom get back get back to
everybody we're celebrating we're
celebrating all all the all the fun
stuff we're just so excited go back to
the banquet we have like a banquet after
the ncaa's every year with all the fans
and uh the the teammates and stuff and
all the guys that aren't starters that
are there too and so
do that and then we it was in Columbus
so we dropped we're driving back and uh
coach kill texts me we're on the bus
he's in the front and I'm like sitting
in the middle of the bus or something
and he's like hey
just want to let you know best interview
I've ever heard and I was like
what'd I say like I have no idea and so
I'm like all right I gotta find this so
I go look in the interview and uh
I just like went off it was it was it
was great because it was so raw so much
emotion that that built up to that
moment and led into that and I just kind
of like gave gave it to the Ohio State
people a little bit and and hype Penn
stayed up and the the guy asked me the
one question
um
he was like uh
I I don't even remember if the the
question applied to the answer but I was
just like
I said a couple of things but I was like
I train every day so I come out here and
be an NCAA Champion for Penn State
uh and I was like I was like that's just
what we do I was like I was like that's
what we do and everybody loved that so
they loved I say I just said that's what
we do and then uh
he goes how about that sequence at the
end and I go man I've been doing that
movie since I was six
I was like I knew he was going to his
back and uh yeah but anyways it was just
like a great interview and people loved
it and stuff I just gotta like hype up
the Penn State Community a little bit
and and we did it right in the middle of
Columbus too which was which was big but
that was kind of like at that moment in
my career it's definitely when I look
back at my college career the easily the
biggest moment the best moment that that
I had it was fun
um next season you go up to 197. is that
just because you're getting bigger and
stronger and older or I wanted a new
challenge and and I didn't want to I was
weighing 190. I was like I don't want to
have to lose six pounds I want to enjoy
this senior year and let's have a good
time and the other thing was my best
friend Anthony who had been 197 for us
he was going to heavyweight and I was
like well this was perfect I'll bump up
and it'll be all good good for the team
and so that whole summer
he Anthony is like I said he's the best
dude in the world my best friend
he had a rough go
up to that point
he had had three labrum surgeries on his
shoulder and uh he had never really got
a shot you know lost like I said his
three years of of competition of
Eligibility and
wasn't able to compete and uh he was out
cutting from 197 from about 220. so big
97 he's like I'm going heavyweight that
was part of the plan you know let's do
it and I'm like all right bro let's ride
together let's do this so the whole
summer lifting 5 000 calories a day
literally it was wake up
six eggs sausage all that go freaking
work out go hammer more food work out
again like that's that's just what we
were just had a great schedule it was
the best hey you what about your knee
this is going back what did you get
surgery and everything or no so it
wasn't 100 torn it was like 80 torn and
I They Don't Really operate on them so I
just kind of let it ride so it's still
it bothers me once in a while but not
very often I'm it's LCL is not nearly as
serious like you know ACL MCL so I uh
yeah after I think the winning kind of
helped it heal feel better yeah yeah uh
and this season you crush again yeah you
come out of 197 it's just it was fun it
was just like a fun
every every competition every match I
was very present very excited it was
like let's just enjoy this let's have a
good time and let's freaking whip some
ass like that's that's what we're here
to do right like let's whoop some ass
let's smile I started doing this thing
where
I was pinning guys and the first time I
happened I pinned this kid from Ohio
State it was actually number one versus
number two in the country first time
we'd ever wrestled bone pin him in like
60 seconds and he was so sad he was
laying there he was like oh so sad and
it's so fun for me I don't want
wrestling to be like that for people so
I just grabbed him I was like yeah it's
all good bro like help him up hit him on
the back all good and then I started
doing this thing where I'm like all
right I'm gonna start helping people up
so I'm pinning people helping them up
like hey keep your head up bro it's all
good and uh
but reality I'm really just trying to be
there for my team be there for those
guys you know I'm still grinding still
working and uh
you know doing my thing but it's it's
just enjoying it enjoying this this
moment the team Race wasn't really close
so there was no stress on that and I
just knew I was
heads into like heads above everybody
kind of so it was now just let's just go
out and dominate and improve it and
smash everybody and I just wanna
end this on on a fun note but really be
there for Anthony because this is first
year you know his only year his only
shot and he's got to be Gable Stevenson
so it's like
that's a guy's a monster you know and
and this is a big challenge so you know
me and him are pushing each other in
practice I'm having to wrestle a 245
pound kid every day so help me get a lot
better my techniques got to be
absolutely on point not to mention he's
easily like the strongest dude I've ever
competed against so
we're we're getting after we're doing
that big tens comes around I'm I'm
killing it I'm like it's a formality for
me like dominate these people and
Anthony's got cable in the finals and so
you know I've finished my match he's
wrestling you know it's like super tight
super close one to one and uh
45 seconds ish left Gable takes him down
like it's like a nice I think an angle
pick gets behind him boom and then
Anthony like I'm like dang dude like
this is freaking there's not that much
time left what's he gonna do but but he
gets up right away and uh
then I'm like all right like he's so
explosive so strong like this is a good
position for him to be in so I think
they go out of bounds and then uh maybe
20 seconds left or so he's faking he's
moving he pulls hits his like signatory
does this little like pull around snap
catches the leg and then just runs
through him boom takes him down I'm like
let's go come on you got it now he's got
10 seconds holds him to hold him down he
holds him down it's like he has like one
kind of crazy scramble he's like up too
high but he gets back boom when's the
match and is in Minnesota so it was in
their freaking home home crowd and I'm
like freaking I'm like let's go come on
that's what I'm talking about and so
then I'm like all right you got to do
like I'm like you just gotta do it one
more one more time like no big deal but
um
I'm not I'm not really worried about
myself so much you know I'm more just
like
I'm gonna I'm gonna do my thing and so
NCH NCAA comes and uh the year before I
didn't have a great NCAA tournament
aside from the finals so now I'm like
all right let's let's put exclamation
point on this so you know start smashing
people up pin a bunch of guys make the
finals and uh
but before that in the semis so for some
reason they put Anthony and Gable on the
same side they were like number two
three seed I think there was an
undefeated kid from Oklahoma State on
the other side something like that so
they got a match up in the semis so I
win my semi match but then they make me
do all these interviews with ESPN and so
I'm doing all these interviews but I'm
watching him on the TV and I'm freaking
out super tight match like come on
what's going on like this is crazy and
uh
so um then at the uh I'm trying to think
of what what the big moment was so yeah
so there was a big moment Anthony gets
taken down right away
end of the SEC or end of the third
period
oh he and he gets called for stalling
twice so he's like down three points now
so then he's like uh kind of trying to
come back he gets he gets a couple
escapes and then
um he's down one and and the third and
Gable like takes a bad shot boom Anthony
runs around him and I'm like oh go come
on let's go but I'm like there's a lot
of time left so he's obviously gonna get
escape and uh
but Anthony's like holding him down for
a while and I look I'm like oh he's got
riding time like let's go he's about to
go up two and so holds him down for a
while and then uh and you can see
Gable's like getting tired he's like
having a hard time getting up and I'm
like
what's happening so it gets but I think
Anthony gets riding Time Boom gets an
escape there's like 30 seconds left and
Cable's just coming at him come out and
come out and he can't get called for
strong so he's trying to like Circle
back in take some shots this and that
and and but Gable just doesn't have the
juice he just doesn't have the gas Tony
freaking wins and I'm like let's go this
is perfect and uh so then we're both in
the finals and
they decide that uh that I'm not gonna
be the last match 197. he's heavyweight
so he's gonna be the first match oh and
so I'm like okay this is kind of good
kind of bad one he's never wrestled
first but two I'll at least get to like
be relaxed and watch him because
normally I don't really get to see him
but the other thing was he lost earlier
in the year and now he's got the kid in
the finals who he lost to and so I'm
like Frick like they lost he lost a
close match to him but it wasn't like
that it was close like on the scoreboard
but it wasn't like uh
it was like Anthony never really had he
never really was like about to take him
down so I'm like all right dude come on
you can do this
so you go zero zero first period he gets
an escape and then second period
um
there's like 20 seconds left
beautiful single leg shot Anthony hits
picks it up and the dude like just does
something dumb weird like Anthony's
gonna take him down but the dude like
just falls on his back like tries to
like kick out and he just jumps on him
and I'm like let's go hold him on his
back gets six nice out seven zero and
I'm like oh it's over come on he won and
uh yeah third period took him down like
two more times one like eleven to one to
kill the guy and uh just so happy for
him because obviously people see that
moment but I'd been with him five years
up to this point three shoulder
surgeries never having even been able to
compete in an NCAA tournament and now
he's the NCAA champion heavyweight like
best guy in the world nobody more
deserving nobody that works harder
really taught me so much about
discipline commitment and consistency
because he was through all those years
you know I was competing at least he
wasn't even able to do that so me and
him just pushed each other so much and I
was so happy to see him win I was like
we freaking did it like let's go and
then I you know I win my match and we
just kind of ride off in the sunset of
call dressing like all right that part
of our life's over with so you know I I
felt like it ended perfectly I win the
uh Hodge trophy
um and uh
I'm like this was just the ideal cap to
the the college career
now you you go to the Olympic trials
what what's your what's your thoughts on
going to the Olympics like where's
where's that because you're doing it
also like in between each season of
wrestling in college you're doing like
World tournaments or yeah Olympic trials
types tournaments and freestyle
tournaments and stuff like this so what
just give us a quick brief on all that
yeah so I I was wrestling freestyle
quite a bit you know it's a different
style
um obviously in in college wrestling
it's just different rule sets in the
Olympics and so I'm mainly focused on
the college style and uh
but in the summer yeah doing doing some
freestyle training and I have a you know
a big goal of mine was to win Olympic
gold medal that was always something I
wanted to do and so basically uh
in 2019 I I start kind of my freestyle
career I compete at the U23 like the
university World Championships I win the
university World Championships and um
feeling pretty good and then uh
getting ready for 2020 trials and boom
covid I'm like Frick what the heck life
just gets paused for a year so I just
okay what am I gonna do I just kind of
they shut Penn State down we can't
really train so we're trying to figure
out places to train and uh
you know everything's just kind of in
limbo so then I guess towards the end of
the year it kind of gets lightened up a
little bit I get married and uh which is
great and then you know get back into
training we're getting ready for Olympic
trials
um so basically just at that point I was
I knew I wanted to fight MMA I was like
you know I was planning on starting MMA
after the Olympics in 2020. with covet I
had to push everything back I was
building a gym in in State College near
Penn State and that got pushed back as
well so it was kind of just a weird time
for me for everybody and you know
getting ready for the trials
I felt like
I wasn't really
at my best physically you know I had
some some stuff that I really wasn't
able to train through and things that I
wasn't really able to
um I just wasn't able to be like as
prepared as I wanted to be I make the
finals and I'm wrestling one of my
teammates David Taylor Who's great
wrestler you know world champion at this
point and
um lose the match you know it's it's
pretty pretty rough pretty upsetting
just the
now you know
knowing that
I'm not going to be able to compete in
the Olympics and
I just got to make a decision you know
do I want to continue to train through
2024 or do I want to fight because my
plan was you know when the Olympics and
and then obviously be done I don't have
to prove any more in wrestling I can
just move on and so there was a lot of
questioning and soul searching in my
mind of
what do I want to do I've had this goal
of being Olympic gold medalist for a
very long time but
I'm definitely more excited and
passionate about fighting and more
interested in
getting involved in that and if I wait
till 20 after 2024
we're talking starting at
28 or starting at you know 25 like
that's a pretty big difference yeah so
yeah to me the the decision came down to
just
I have this big goal but I'm not going
to let this big goal get in the way of
what I'm really truly where my heart's
calling me what I'm really passionate
about and what I really want to do I
felt like I would be
doing like a disservice to myself if I
had continued to wrestle which I still
love wrestling I still wrestle all the
time but
my my goals and achievements they don't
Define me that's that's just part of
that's what I've done I've just done
those things it's not who I am as a
person so it was it was tough and it
took you know a lot of
kind of just thoughts and talking with
people and but I I knew that was the
right move for me so get the gym built
in August of uh 2021 I actually didn't I
wasn't able to train
um from April even until then because
the injuries I had and stuff I had to
just rehab and whatnot and then uh got
back after in August
and took my first amateur fight like
five weeks later
uh
who's your first amateur fight against
and and like that's just not cool dude
that's just not cool I know I actually
have had many many fighters that you
know come through my gym and I want to
fight I wanna fight I want to fight and
I'm like hey dude like you've been
training for nine months and sure you
might there's a decent there's a chance
you can fight someone that's been
training for six months there's also a
chance do you fight someone that's been
wrestling since they were six years old
right and you're gonna get annihilated
so you need to get better before you go
and fight uh when you started training
so so where who did you bring in what
was the situation yeah so I partnered
with American top team and we basically
built an American top team in State
College so they do franchises that are
um you know I I don't know exactly the
business structure but it's like a
franchise fee so there's 40 of them or
whatever all in Florida in the Southeast
but this was like a real partnership
with the headquarters so the
headquarters like directly backs and
funds to Jim and they uh provide the
coaches and built the whole facility out
and stuff so basically I met them
through my management team and just got
along with them very well because I felt
like two things I felt like one they
were very structured relative to what
most MMA kind of training situations
what I've seen and they also just had a
lot of really high level guys and high
level guys in different areas from me
you know had a lot of high level Jiu
Jitsu high level Muay Thai striking and
they had good wrestling as well like you
know but I felt like that complimented
me very well and it was just a good fit
to partner up with them so
I spend probably 80 90 percent of my
time in State College in PA but then
when I'm able to I go down to Coconut
Creek in Florida and train with the main
main gym at the headquarters there and
it's been a really good system for me so
far and they just wanted to support and
start this and partner with me because
where they saw my career going and also
all the possible connections with Penn
State wrestling and the wrestlers that
want to come up and start to fight you
know once they're done with their
wrestling career so it's a it's a little
pipeline we're creating yeah that's a
big badass actually would you when did
you first do Jiu Jitsu
so my first experience with Jiu Jitsu
was when I was in college so I was doing
a camp in I think St Louis Missouri
wrestling camp and uh this guy his kid
was wrestling at the camp and he was
like Hey I do Jiu Jitsu do you want to
like come up and roll we're doing
practice right here if you want to go uh
it's in the wrestling room at the high
school we just have a little club and I
was like I okay let's go and uh so I go
in and uh I have no idea what's going to
happen I've obviously I've watched tons
of fighting I've watched some Jiu Jitsu
because I'm just interested in Combat
Sports and stuff but I've never really
done
any Jiu Jitsu ever and uh
so they start me off with a guy and like
it's just like a regular guy and and I'm
going with them I'm kind of like put him
on the ground take us back choke him
whatever get a geek just from watching
yeah just from watching yeah just from
watching my style with wrestling was
always very like I was always focused on
the pen and so the pin is very similar
like there'd be wrestling matches where
I'd get a guy in like a like a like we
called a snake like a cement job and I
like I choke multiple guys out cold like
that not on purpose but just they're
trying to fight off their back I'm
squeezing their neck boom they go out so
that wasn't really a foreign feeling to
me like choking people but now it was
allowed so what I always teach so I
teach
um clinics and stuff and what I teach is
all right
we're not in wrestling we're not going
to choke this guy that's illegal in
wrestling we don't choke we're just
gonna make it really hard for them to
breathe so that's like how I teach so it
kind of It Came fairly natural so I
tapped the guy out and stuff and then
they're like all right how about like
try this blue belt I'm like okay so same
thing you know kind of he these guys
aren't like competing at a high level
they're just practitioners and you know
and they're not really even like they're
not great they're just having fun and so
kind of same thing and they're like
all right what about this dude like
purple belt and then later on purple
belt same thing and then they're like
all right this guy's Brown this this is
no gee I'm assuming yeah okay well so
it's all these guys are no gee at this
point yeah and they're like all right
try this guy he's like uh he's a brown
belt and then we kind of go at it a
little bit like five minutes or so six
minutes and uh
at the end
um I just I never like subbed him but I
was like taking this back kind of like
moving around and like God I'm tired and
he wasn't really able to like hang with
me and then I was like that at this
point they had slowly been like stopping
their practice and just watching me and
uh now at this point it's like just us
and everybody's watching and they're
like go against the instructor go into
the instructor I'm like Frick I don't
want to do this this is his class like
whatever Let's Do It
um and he's an older guy he's probably
60 he's running a ghee black belt like
really nice guy too and uh so he
immediately pulls guard the other guys
were kind of trying to wrestle me a
little bit like they didn't know and uh
but he just pulls guard
goes half guard just like locks me down
like uh it's called lockdown I think
right yeah like lock that and I'm like
he's in a ghee I'm like not moving and
uh we're kind of sitting there and like
just in his stalemate he tried to wrist
lock me once and was like cranking on my
wrist and I was like get off me but I'm
like don't know what I'm doing so I'm
like kind of trying to pass or trying to
figure out what to do but we just end up
in a stalemate for like 10 minutes and
uh so we were just kind of stuck there
and then everybody's like all right time
like you're done and I'm like all right
we're done and then so that was my whole
first experience with Jiu Jitsu and then
the guy was they were all super nice
super cool and the guy like gave me a
t-shirt from their club and stuff and we
took a picture together and stuff it was
it was really cool so that was my first
experience and at that moment
I really liked it and I was like
oh I'm fighting I gotta fight MMA like
I'm gonna do it for sure yeah this is so
fun when was like when's the first time
you rolled with someone that was really
good at Jiu Jitsu that like yeah worked
you over yeah and choked you and you
were like yo this is yeah I need to
learn this stuff well I'm I've never
really been like worked over and choked
I wouldn't say
um just because like I I think my my
skills translate well
so the first actually I'll say this the
first guy that whooped me was a guy from
Pittsburgh Isaac Greeley so he wrestled
at upj and he's older now he's probably
40 45 and uh shout out to the old dudes
yeah let's go yeah yeah he's uh like
he's he's like Renzo Gracie black belt
like Beast like runs his own club Matt I
don't know if you ever heard of Matt
Factory but yeah they have a lot of good
guys that that he so he trains everybody
out of map Factory and uh like first
time we're old with Isaac that's
actually not true when I said I never
got like a whip because he whipped my
ass he was like choking me throwing me
down and he's smaller than me too he's
like probably 170. yeah if you don't
know
dude that's what's gonna happen yeah and
obviously you're gonna learn freaking
yeah exponential
incredible rate but I figured there had
to be at least somebody that makes you
say already he was the guy yeah that
like kind of he kind of but you gotta I
wasn't going with like
I wasn't going to
take time out of what I was doing go to
legit Jiu Jitsu gym where these guys are
freaking beasts yeah you know so I was
able to kind of learn slow and then like
start challenging myself a little bit oh
but I forgot because that's actually not
true so I worked I had never worked with
Isaac and uh so I had done that one
session I guess session called where all
the dudes rotated in on me and then
in uh
2020 when covet happened
um so this was the first time I got
whooped actually and 2021 code happened
there it was like like decemberish and I
followed Gordon Ryan on Instagram and uh
oh yeah okay yeah so I follow him on
Instagram and he was like
trying to get a match or like three
people drop out and I was like I'll
freaking do it these none of these dudes
will grapple you like let's go like I'll
do it like I don't care and uh he was
like all right like let me talk to the
promoter and stuff so I'm like all right
let's do it so we get we get it all
agreed to
and I'm like just try to make it like
somewhat fair I don't know anything so
no like no guard pulling no he's like no
guard pulling no leg locks I'm like
that's fine whatever I don't even no
guard pulling no leg locks okay so he
wasn't allowed to pull guard not allowed
to pull guard and not allowed he wasn't
now do leg locks right yeah so that
means you would get to take his ass down
yeah and you would at least not get your
leg torn leg torn off okay these seem
like appropriate rules fairly fair and
so
they're like all right eight minute
match blah blah this now I'm like done
let's do it and so we get there and
um
I'm like what weight are we going and
I'm like I'm like whatever I'm here so I
weigh like 202 and he's like 2 30. and
I'm like whatever I don't care he's big
yeah he's big he's a big dude yeah yeah
so I was like whatever let's go I'm here
and we get to they want to do a rules
clinic so I'm like okay fine they're
like all right match give me 15 minutes
I'm like
well that's different but whatever okay
let's do it and uh
then him and danaher proceed to like
mostly dinner like Grill the refs and
the and the judges the people for like
45 minutes about what if this happens
what if the rules are happening what is
that I should have paid more attention
because I was just like what are these
guys doing like I'm a freaking wrestler
I've never done a Jitsu match in my life
so I I did go out to Pittsburgh and
train like a couple times I did three
practices legit practices where I was
like trying to learn stuff before the
competition because it was like 10 days
and I was like competing you know so
um they're asking all these questions
and I'm like yo I'm here to compete like
I don't care like whatever like let's go
like
I was just confused why they're grilling
them I'm like I should be the one doing
this night y'all because y'all know
what's going on yeah so we get to the
match and
in my mind I was thinking
that
going into it I was like I'm gonna win
this match I'm going to go 14 minutes
and 20 seconds or 40 minutes and 50
seconds and take him down and score in
10 seconds he's never gonna take me down
he's not gonna happen I was way more
excited about eight because then I was
like that's easy I can go seven and a
half no problem but then they started
saying stuff in the meeting they're like
if you get called for stalling we're
going to take out like half your purse
you get called again we're gonna take
your whole purse and I was like that's
so stupid like what do you mean and so
the match starts and uh
in my mind I'm thinking I'm not going to
shoot if I once that because they were
the questions they were asking were oh
if I shoot then he could pull guard it
was like if I grab a single leg he could
pull guard so I'm like I'm not gonna put
myself in a bad position obviously if I
get in the guard or get in a situation
like that I'm no nothing so you know I
want to be in that as little as possible
and so he actually freaking like
scissors sweep me right off the bat and
like come like tore my MCL it didn't 100
tear it but it like tore it like a good
bit to where a few months after that I
tore it 90 in practice which sucked but
yeah and freaking messed me up and then
um but I didn't really feel it that much
in the match but uh
so we go through the match and there's
like
I don't know two minutes left or
something I'm like I think I got this
like I'm gonna win and he starts backing
up into me and like like turning his
back uh towards me and like backing up
so that I'll try to take him down so
then he could do Jiu Jitsu right and I'm
like I don't want to do Jitsu and so
he's doing this and everybody's kind of
like oh like making a noise in the crowd
I'm like I gotta freaking do something
so he's backing up grabbing suplex him
and now that's the clip that everybody
sees is me suplexing him which is a good
thing I guess but so I suplex him and
then I get up and I'm like oh hell yeah
like that's like now we separated and
um I gotta take down it's tied and it
was two they gave him two points for
something at the beginning and they gave
me two so it's tied and there's a minute
and a half left I'm like this is
beautiful I'm gonna go one more takedown
yeah I'm gonna go one more takedown at
the end like and I'm gonna win and uh
so but then after I took him down then
all of a sudden he starts pulling guard
and he's like scooting towards me and
I'm like what the hell is going on like
why are we not like but they they were
yelling in Portuguese at me and I'm like
I don't know what that means so then
whatever but I guess they're saying that
once I got the takedown he could pull
guard which obviously he was on the
ground he could stay on the ground yeah
something like that yeah and so I'm like
okay whatever so now I'm like I can't
just run away so I got to try to engage
so I don't know what I'm doing so then
he he goes shoulder crunch on me which I
I've watched some film on him so I know
he loves to do that so I just sit back
because I got good hips so I'm like he's
not just gonna freaking sweep me over
here like if I obviously put all my
weight on him he's gonna do that so I'm
sitting back
beautiful triangle right over my uh
shoulder I try to stand up dumbest thing
I could have done I don't know and then
I'm like I just gotta try to slam him I
guess I'd go to slam and he switched to
arm bar kind of it didn't hurt my elbow
but like he would have and uh then I'd
try to slam boom tight over I'm like
son of a one minute left I'm like
I could have freaking got him like
obviously in this this rule set but then
I'm then I'm pissed but overall it was a
good experience for me yeah you know I I
loved Jujitsu it was really fun
I hate that I lost like it pisses me off
no you lost through the freaking literal
best like I don't know Grappler in the
history so to me one don't feel too bad
about it it doesn't really matter like
you know I just think how cool it had
been for me for wrestling Community
going there one first graphic match win
like most time wrestlers roll in and
like do something like that which they
don't do often and they get killed in 20
seconds but if I would have won it would
have been like ultimate cred forever you
know so to me it's like
hard because
I'm not full-time in Jiu Jitsu I've
really never trained up to that point
and I lost
so I I technically shouldn't be that mad
at myself but I also just see like what
that could have been it could have been
so cool for me and uh you know now I
like I don't know if I'll ever get
another like I I don't know if I'll ever
get to compete against him again like
hopefully we'll train and stuff but and
like I don't know how long he's gonna
compete my plan is when I'm done with
MMA
all grappling like I'm gonna do ADCC all
that stuff but I just don't have time
right now so yeah
yeah that's awesome I got
maybe a little bit of flack the other
day somebody took a clip from our
podcast sure where I said
there's a couple key things that I said
I said pure wrestler against pure Jiu
Jitsu fight
the Jiu jitsu's guy is gonna win nine
times out of ten listen I love wrestling
definitely I think wrestling is the best
possible base you can have for MMA I
think it's what every kid should do I
think it's awesome
but the problem is they literally don't
know how to finish a fight they just
don't know how to do it and so that's
what a jiu jitsu guy knows how to do and
what you just said was like you just and
the reason I'm bringing this up because
you just kind of backed me up bro I got
the I got the freaking King wrestle
right here you said look normally it's
like 20 seconds if you don't know Jiu
Jitsu at all
you take the guy down great and you get
unlocked you take the guy I don't get
guillotine like it you just don't you're
just not used to that kind of thing
a month later of training that wrestler
is now murdering this jujitsu guy that's
why it was key component was like pure
versus pure that really doesn't even
exist anymore even you knew how to choke
people you know without any training at
all so uh please you know a little Mercy
on the kid over here you know I didn't
yeah I mean I don't I don't know why
people would be like mad at Pride about
that it's I think probably
you know yeah it makes perfect sense if
you got somebody that's wrestling
against somebody that's doing jiu jitsu
it's not going to be like like the Jiu
Jitsu guy's gonna win as soon as he as
soon as the guy shoots they're gonna get
geeked and get triangle get armed like
something right I can tell you I have
gone against especially in the early
days when I was like a blue belt so
we're talking mid mid 90s
I I went against all kinds of wrestlers
for high school college wrestlers I mean
and I never like lost I never got like
some they don't even know what a
submission was how could I lose like
it's not happening so that was sort of
what I based that opinion on and I gave
the benefit of that like sometimes I'm
sure a guy might grab you know put you
in a cradle and crank your freaking head
off and be like yo this is what's going
down but um yeah so I think this like
now with MMA being so prominent and
stuff people see like everybody knows
how to lock like a rear naked show or a
guillotine or or even like DARS like
people like that have never done Jiu
Jitsu like a lot of people know how to
do that stuff not a lot of people a lot
of like combat athletes like they'll
know all right this is how to do it but
they don't really know
actual like Jiu Jitsu for me at the
beginning when I started doing grappling
it was all right just don't get
submitted like all right I'm gonna
control this dude and then I don't even
know how I'm gonna like my best chance
the only time I really submitted guys
was because I was just so much better of
an athlete or I'll get him tired and
they'll give their backs up or something
like that and I know how to do like like
something simple right but you don't
really know how to compete in sport Jiu
Jitsu right like if you take a guy down
you're sitting in guard
and you don't know how to pass guard you
don't know how to like do anything
you're eventually are gonna just they're
gonna get you who's your consistent
coach in in your gym so Jiu Jitsu for
jiu jitsu we have uh iotan Barboza he's
ATT guy so he he competed a lot and uh
the cool thing about him is he competed
at a very high level in Jiu Jitsu you
know he started off Judo then got into
Jiu Jitsu as a teen and then you know
competed at a high level and then uh
since then he had like close to 20 MMA
fights so he has a lot of practical MMA
Jiu Jitsu which is great for me right
like I love the sports Jiu Jitsu but I
need to know practical top game stuff
because and and defending submissions
and then you know stuff that's specific
to what I'm doing hell yeah you don't
need much bottom game yeah yeah I like
it I like honestly like when I'm rolling
like I'll play bottom and stuff like
that it's fun but I it doesn't really
I'm never gonna do that in a fight yeah
no no uh so you get your first fight you
knock somebody out in a minute or
whatever that's a a amateur fight and
then the next thing was Contender Series
right no so I took so basically what
happened was I scheduled two amateur
fights in a row I did one I did another
one three weeks later and then um I was
really working hard I want to make my
Pro debut at Penn State and State
College so we were trying to like get
licensing put a promotion together work
with my management team work with Penn
State and I wanted to do a fight in Rec
Hall like it was going to be insane in
uh in April so when the students were in
in town and like you know we were so
close to getting it done and then the PA
athletic commission and between them
Penn State my management team it was
just we weren't going to get it done and
so I had gone from
October through April and not got in a
fight and I was like guys I need to get
a freaking give me a freaking fight so
some random dummy called me out at like
this promotion was like I want bow
nickel blah blah nickel and I was like
okay let's do it pro pro MMA debut in
Richmond Virginia I did it in June and
uh it was on UFC Fight Pass so
there have been people you know paying a
little bit of attention to me and stuff
in MMA but
not a lot and then I made my Pro debut
and uh
boom stray left hand uppercut hook knock
the dude out in 30 seconds and everybody
lose their mind and uh immediately the
next day UFC's calling bellator's con
one of every promotion's calling wanting
to sign me and it's crazy and and now
it's like
well I can go with these promotions but
I need to get more experience I need to
get some fights and uh
you know nobody on the regional scene is
gonna who's gonna fight me now like I
just knocked this dude out cold I'm an
NCAA Champion wrestler like how am I
gonna get a fight so we my management
team and I decided it was always the UFC
for me that was the path and uh they
really wanted me because my my knockout
that promotion it did the most views in
Fight Pass history over over like the
next week out of any event that they
ever done I did like I don't know three
or four million views over the next week
and so then they were like motivated
because they you know they obviously saw
the views they saw what I did which you
know knocked out with my hands which was
big and then they're like all right what
can we do to get you experience boom
gave you two fights on contenders or
let's get you one fight on contenders oh
that's right it turned into one fight
well it was it was interesting because
so I go into uh oh no you did you had
two I had two contenders right so I
thought it was going to be one I thought
I was gonna you know go in one fight
then they're like all right we're gonna
get you another fight so so
um they just said let's let's get you on
contenders boom and then Dana's like
let's get you one more so
yeah the contenders thing was great for
me though because I got to just get
experience and I got to
um basically
get these fights that I these guys
wouldn't have fought me if it wouldn't
have been in contenders oh okay it's
like none of those guys would accept to
fight me for
500 bucks yeah local shows no but now
it's like okay if I want to get in the
UFC let's do it so now I can get the
fights and then from there I was ready
to you have any good nerves at all going
into these fights well the first one I
was a little nervous because you know
bigger stage my first one and uh
but but I knew like
literally any fight I go into is the
dude has 60 seconds two minutes to knock
me out if that doesn't happen it's over
it's like I'm Gonna Get You On The
Ground I'm gonna beat the crap out of
you I'm gonna choke you out I'm gonna do
whatever I want because you got a short
window of time to win this fight so as
soon as I get a hold of them I'm like oh
it's over like I'm not nervous at all
but until then it's like okay let's
figure this out like let me get close to
you but uh then my second fight I was
nervous because
10 days before that I was riding home
from practice on a one wheel have you
seen these yeah they're like weird
looking skateboards yeah skateboard with
a big wheel yeah and uh so it sounds
like a smart move coming up it's not a
roll
but uh no pun intended but I'm riding
back from practice and I live 200 yards
from the gym so but there's a main road
that's like 45 mile an hour speed limit
and uh so I'm riding down this road
and the one wheel doesn't work when you
wear flip-flops so you I take my shoes
off so I have my flip-flops my big yeti
bottle my phone my wallet like all the
stuff in my hand on my shirt my shirts
off no nothing uh on just like all that
stuff in my hands and my my buddy
Anthony he's just finished training with
me too he's behind me and uh so I'm like
driving like is he on the one wheel no
no he's on a car okay and so he's like
gone so there's really no reason for you
to be doing this zero this is the
dumbest thing I've ever done so but it
was just fun I just liked riding it so
and it's 200 yards it's like what's
gonna happen like I'm going just real
quick and so he's behind me and uh I'm
going like 15 so they're like rolling
and I'm like frick then another car
comes I'm like oh there I gotta go
faster so I'm like starting to lean
forward and uh
is does this thing where if you lean
forward too far it'll auto correct you
then if you lean forward farther than
that it'll just die and like catch the
nose and he'll just freaking so I'm like
trying to go as fast as I can on this
one wheel to get around the curve to go
to my house and it boom that's exactly
what I said catch the nose 23 miles an
hour I fly off this thing land straight
on my freaking shoulder everything I
have in my hands goes flying in the air
boom hit roll and I'm like I just gotta
get off the road I'm gonna get hit by a
car so I pop up and just run off and
then I Anthony's like look he's like
this and I'm like
and I go grab all my stuff and I jump in
the car and he's like are you okay and
I'm like
let me check and I was like
no no I'm not okay this sucks and uh so
then I I go home I'm like what do I do
I'm like I have to like I can't lift my
shoulder up at all it's like done and so
then I'm like I gotta go get an MRI I
get X-ray so I crack my collarbone and I
uh sprained my SC joint like really
badly and so
we're 10 days away from the fight I'm
like I got I gotta pull out like I'm not
gonna be able to play I can't lift my
arm and so we have an athletic trainer
at Penn State I'm like I'm gonna give it
like three more days and uh he's like a
magician right so like any injury I've
ever had he's helped me it's just like
he does a lot of Eastern medicine stuff
it's insane and so he starts working on
me and he's like like you don't got a
lot of tissue there so it's not really
going to heal super fast but we'll do
what we can so he starts working on me
and
the first day I was like I saw
Improvement I was like okay
this is a possibility the second day I
saw a little more Improvement and I was
like
all right I'm gonna give it one more day
we'll see where we're at and the third
day to proved a little more I still I
could go to like about here and like
move pretty slow but I could move and I
was like
fights on let's go I can move my arm so
that made me nervous I wouldn't have
been nervous but freaking like I said
broke my collarbone and messed myself up
so
um
then I just I just didn't really train
just kind of got my weight down and by
the time I was about to fight it was
like I could box and do stuff but it was
just painful it was like I could move
the way I wanted to move but I just felt
pain while I was doing it which is not
ideal but we could fight so luckily
freaking boom stray left hand knocking
Dude down triangle finish him in like 50
seconds and I'm like thank the Lord
[Music]
uh so I don't ride the one wheel anymore
yeah is this the main story yeah then
you get your first fight in the actual
UFC right yeah is that the right thing
to say the actual UFC because it's not
the contenders yeah so I was supposed to
fight in December right after that that
was in October or something and now I I
finished that fight and I was like let's
go December let's run it and I get back
home and I was like
ooh this is not really I need to need to
fix this so it's all good move it to
March but yeah I get my first fight in
March in the UFC
crazy like 3-0 and I'm like
let's go main card too right main card
open in the main card Jon Jones
pay-per-view
this is wild it was wild
yeah any nerves on that one definitely
yeah yeah I mean I feel nervous for
every time I compete I think that did
you feel nervous before the NCAA
championships because the only time I
didn't was my senior year in the finals
because I was just so much better than
everybody it was more like
it was hard to get excited for it it was
just kind of like all right let's let's
do this let's let's finish on a good
note but every other time I'm like
like what makes you feel nervous in the
UFC is it like the crowd is it the
possibility you get knocked out is it
your career goals I think it's just how
much I put into what I do
and I
spend so much time and effort to
go perform and I know these moments are
so short and and finite and there's only
a few of them that you get so I really
really
put pressure on myself to perform to the
best of my ability and then of course
there's nerves for man
I do not want to get knocked out cold on
national TV
I do not want to get freaking there's
always that risk like my entire family
is watching and I'm putting myself in a
very dangerous situation so you know
I do not I want and I want to win you
know so to me like the the nervousness
it comes from from those two areas and I
think one's very negative and one's very
positive so I really try to lean into
the positivity and and replace the
negativity the negative one with with
other things with uh just more positive
loving feelings
and that's so that's your kind of
protocol yeah pretty much how much you
warm up
um I would say like 40 minutes before
I'll probably go for like
a hard 20 minutes like I get my heart up
I don't wanna I used to do this thing
where I'd roll out and wrestle cold and
I would still go Pentagon in 60 seconds
but I found overall long term I get
better results when I warm up pretty
pretty good so I'll get a good sweat and
get that heart rate up and uh yeah then
I give myself about 15-ish minutes to
cool down before it's go time
how about the next fight
yeah so and that this was your last
fight right yeah my most recent fight
was freaking sweet it was so much better
um well there was one little hiccup the
first fight I was very nervous I you
know wanted to perform really well and
the guy was fighting was dangerous he's
like six three super long Southpaw
awkward it's like that was not a great
fight you know but
he was the guy they they brought to me
and we're gonna make it work so
um and it wasn't like he was an absolute
killer but he was just awkward and
dangerous and had good power athletic so
yeah you get caught you get caught yeah
so I was nervous but then you know the
second fight and by the way that one was
the arm triangle yeah yeah so the second
fight I was like kind of uh I was way
loose I was like I'm about to mess this
dude up like we're ready to go camp was
was amazing no injuries all healthy wake
up was perfect I actually you know I
came down I came in a little heavier
than what I normally do but that was
planned I wanted to be a little bigger
and I felt amazing what are you walking
around at right now I'm probably I'm a
little light right now but normally like
in training camp I'm 206 to 208 I'm
probably 202 204 right now what are your
week of
so week of all come in like lower than
200 like 98.99 and you just go like all
water night before I'll do seven day
water six day water load and then uh
yeah just like cut the calories a little
bit but it's mostly just the water load
and sauna and stuff I I try to limit as
sauna and Plastics as much as I can but
it's very intuitive based on I've done
it so it's like no factor for you not no
not at all no I feel yeah I've never
missed I've never miss weight in my life
no I've been weighing in since I was
five so never miss weights yeah yeah so
it's it's not an issue
um but yeah the hiccup was my opponent
pulling out of the fight you know Monday
I get a call I just finished a training
well I actually hadn't even finished I
was in the middle of my training session
and my mom comes up to me and she's like
yo mouthy's on the phone my my agent and
I'm like
pissed I'm like why are you coming to me
with a phone call in the middle of my
I'm about to like hit pads like and then
he's like I'm like can it wait and she's
like no it's important and I'm like I
knew immediately when she said that I
was like
damn it so he tells me he's pulling out
I heard it hurt his wrist or something
and I'm like
I just wasted like 10 weeks and I bought
40 tickets for family and friends and
what are we gonna this is I paid I got
an Airbnb for the whole week like you
know not to mention I'm just not gonna
get to perform that sucks so
Frick and mouth he's like all right
we'll work on it let me let me call you
in a little bit so like 45 minutes later
he calls me back he's like we got two
names for you
and uh I'm like give me whichever one
signs I don't care and uh he's like all
right well like we're gonna have the
coaches watch them film and stuff I'm
like okay fine so as my coaches watch
film they're like all right check this
dude out I watch him in two minutes and
I'm like done I'll sign let's go and uh
you know I told myself it's funny
because I told myself going into mmm
like I'm not doing last minute
Replacements I'm not coming in it's like
I'm a professional all we're gonna do is
for real but then I get into the moment
and I'm like let's go I'm fighting like
I will you could throw out the freaking
incredible Hulk like we could go I'm
ready ready to get it and so
um yeah so he signed the contract
luckily fortunately I I obviously signed
the contract and then it was just back
on business as usual which was just such
a blessing because I just thought it was
done how are you feeling in Training
Camps like what are you what are you
focused on in Training Camps do you I
mean obviously
and I was thinking about this earlier
and talking about doing all your
different sports that's probably why
your striking is able to get up to speed
so quickly like if you just wrestled
your whole life you wouldn't be striking
the way you're striking no but because
you were throwing balls and playing
other sports and like that your just
athleticism is through the roof uh so
but what are you concentrating on I
would say the main thing that I focus on
is just my base and fundamentals is
agility you know being able to move
forward backwards side to side with both
stances and uh
just just keeping that Foundation solid
and building good habits is the main
thing you know the strikes and the
combinations
when you put yourself in good position
and you're in good position you can do
whatever you want it doesn't really
matter like you throw a knee elbow punch
whatever whatever you the main thing to
me and striking is
my understanding my range understanding
how to have agility be able to move and
and they always say this in Jiu Jitsu
position before submission right it's
the exact same thing it's striking it's
getting a good position then whatever
you want to throw is going to land right
be super sound fundamentally on defense
so catching Jabs checking kicks
defending straight right hands as a
southpaw all very big for me and uh yeah
I mean you know you work a little bit of
fundamentals on on the actual strikes
right making sure that left hand that
straight left hand is straight making
sure your right hook is where it needs
to be making sure your jab you know I
have a versatile jab I can throw it to
the head to the body I can throw it slow
I can throw it fast I can throw it to
the glove so I can throw it to the air
different stuff like that you know and
but it's all solid foundation
fundamentals I think where a lot of
people go wrong is they try to do the
combo of the day the one two three slip
two uppercut step back two like it's
like that's not a real fight bro like
let's do some that actually applies so I
think that's why I've been able to get
as good as I have and I just have really
good coaches guys that I listen to and
trust and who are going to keep me
in the right like Lane and mindset of
get this solid-based fundamentals use
your wrestling right like we're never
going to forget about that we're always
going to use my user wrestling but now
how do we mix it up that's kind of My
Philosophy how much wrestling do you do
I wrestle every day pretty much and when
you say right not that much do you do
yeah barely ever every day uh do you do
Jiu Jitsu is that considered wrestling
now kind of like if you if you're going
to train can I slap a guillotine on you
and like you're not like dude this is
wrestling well so what I do is when I'm
I do my wrestling training with Penn
State still oh so I go train with the
college guys but I adjust it a little
bit so like
I'm doing all folk style wrestling
because that's most applicable to MMA
and
I'm always like protecting myself like
of course these guys aren't gonna try to
like they're wrestling they're trying to
get better at wrestling so they're not
going to try to get to me or whatever
but I I just adjust my style a little
bit to where
it's more the way I would compete in MMA
and like let's say I'm going with a dude
and he shoots in some like if I could
put a guillotine on him like I'd put it
on there yeah I'll just show it to him
and just kind of like no I could have
got it obviously he's not trying to
defend me but like me just getting used
to that and stuff and you know then
um when I do like actual grappling
training it's with guys that you know
know what we're trying to trying to do
like you know I do that a couple times a
week yeah so that way you're getting all
that and um
when's the next fight do you know I'll
probably go early next year so right now
I got a couple Elkins coming up so
through September yes sir so I'm super
pumped about that and then
um October uh my buddy Anthony's
fighting so I want to help him get ready
for that and then my wife's having a
baby December so I kind of like it kind
of eliminated like the rest of this year
for me
um because the main thing was
since my wife's pregnant I don't want to
have a situation where all right I'm
fine December 12th boom she goes in
labor and I'm like what the frick you
know so uh I'll probably push it to the
March or April but I think that's good
for me too just with my development I
fought five times in the past year and
you know it's good for me to take some
time and not be in Camp because I've
just been in Camp the whole time
yeah and you've got a baby coming your
wife's a three-time All-American
freaking track athlete Savage so you're
like gonna have a genetic mutant
Offspring as well yeah that's that's the
plan that was kind of but you messed up
the date for wrestling I don't know I
know we'll see so I'm hoping if she's a
week late we're good yeah so we'll see
but uh yeah yeah I'm really excited
about it she's she's the best so you
know
um met my wife in school and whatnot and
uh
yeah I'm excited for us to be parents
it's gonna be insane yeah that's awesome
do you know if you're having a boy or
girl yeah boy yo yeah that's awesome
yeah uh and then on the like on the
business front kind of you got some
things going on there you got scrap life
I see you're wearing a scrap life yes
sir t-shirt so this is like you know
your wrestling apparel and you guys make
shoes and everything yeah we do head to
toe wrestling so that's kind of where we
started
um scrap life was I came onto scrap life
a few years after the brand you know
began and then you know
because of my position and just
what I was bringing to the table they
brought me in as partner and now I do
all of our product development I do our
uh manage a lot of the nil athletes and
our influencers and stuff like that and
yeah there's it's a we're still early in
the business so you kind of got to do a
lot of things when you're early in the
business and it's fun though I really
enjoy it and I've learned so much just
from having to figure things out and
also dealing with people that um
know a lot as well it's it's it's fun
how's that nil athlete stuff are you
pissed uh no you know I think you accept
it I accept it yeah for me it's like I
look back at first I was like oh my gosh
I missed out on so much money this is
insane and then
you know it was like were you gonna cry
about it just get over it and and for me
now it's like
I I always felt like
I don't want the way nil is working is
donors writing checks to athletes it's
like it's not the way it's intended it's
just a donor writing a check and so for
me
I don't know I just I don't really like
the way that it's going the way that
it's trending but I'm also on the other
end excited for kids to be able to make
money and happy for a lot of my friends
that are doing really well so you know
they're and and I'm you know never gonna
beg for a dollar from anybody so I'm
gonna go earn it myself so it's all good
uh then you got your like this recovery
cream that you came out with which you
have some for me which I'm at Camp right
now I need it I thought you need it yes
I got you bro so what's that all about
yeah 27-17 so um it's a recovery cream
that actually um a close family friend
of mine
um basically
uh asked me he was like are you
interested in like this this recovery
cream I work with a scientist and we're
formulating it to uh basically help with
any type of inflammation bump bruise
that type of thing would you want to try
and see how it is and this was
three years ago so this was 2020 2021
and
I was like okay I'll try it whatever and
so I tried it here and there and I kind
of have a bad back bad neck so I'd rub
it and I was like oh like that kind of
helped a little bit but you know I just
kind of kept moving moving on and then
uh right before the Olympic trials in
2021 that was when I tore my MCL 90 so I
kind of like partially tore it with
grappling Gordon and then completely
tore it right before and uh then it was
three months of rehab and just
re-aggravating it like all the time it
would be like train train
Third Day training boom re-aggravate it
and I'm like what the hell you know so
um basically after three months of that
I was like What if I just let me rub
this on it let me see what's up because
I kind of had forgot almost and so I
started putting on my knee you know in
addition to rehab and doing stuff and
then after a month I was like
I'm good to go wow this actually helped
so I hit my family friend back up and I
was like
what's up with this like give me some
more info on it like let me see this so
he gives me some more info gives me some
more out and I was like all right this
worked for me I want to see how my
teammates like it so give someone an off
give some to Kyle Snyder give some to a
few guys that kind of are doing the same
things as me
and then immediately every single one
was like dude send me more this stuff's
sick yeah like let me try it like what
what do you have going on here I'm like
it's just like yeah product we're
working on so then at that point it kind
of became real I knew we had something
so then I kind of
partnered up with
um a financial guy partnered up with my
uncle and uh marketing team and I
basically helped design all the The
Branding the packaging that type of
thing and uh
you know do a lot of the now social
media and whatnot I'm not running the
social but I'm doing the marketing and
it's kind of for me what I've realized
about business is
I have certain strengths you know I have
a good eye for the the look and I'm able
to to help with with that type of stuff
product design and product development
and then what I'm able to do as an
athlete in my own brand and and that
Association so that's kind of the lane I
pick and then I've been trying to fill
in the gaps with other people because I
just couldn't do the other stuff that
needs to be done you know the
the research or the Fulfillment or or
anything on the back end customer
service so you know I I have other
people that help me out with that yeah
no you definitely have your role in this
stuff and you shouldn't be sitting in a
lab somewhere yeah figuring stuff out
what about you know I saw on your
website Bo nickel.com I saw on your
website you it says camps do you
actually do camps once in a while so
when I was in school and wrestling that
was like a huge source of income from it
for me I could do you know 20 camps this
summer and and make good money and stuff
but uh now with with the way my
situation is with fighting I have a few
rental properties a few businesses
um I don't really need to so I will here
and there if it's like a camp for maybe
like a close friend or if somebody
offers me like a lot of money then I'm
like all right well let me see if I can
carve it out but I definitely don't make
it a priority at all and like I do a
camp every summer for my buddy in Texas
who he's a high school wrestling coach
and I want to give back right so to me
that that's a lot of what camps are and
if somebody comes in with something like
astronomical then I'm like all right
we'll make it happen you know but uh
it's really I try to limit them because
it's a lot as you know you know it's a
lot to to go and do that and it takes
away from my training and stuff so you
know for me it has to make sense now is
your gym in PA is that thing Justified
Jim with no or is there like members
there's members oh okay so we have
public class oh no kidding yeah Jiu
Jitsu classes we have Muay Thai we got
boxing classes so oh dang kid
self-defense yeah that's freaking
totally legit I don't run any of them
but you know for me uh my coaches are
the same guys are coaching me are
coaching the public classes which is
pretty cool you know they get that you
know Elite level knowledge to you know
anybody that wants to come in and learn
and uh my goal is
you know obviously right now I'm just
fighting but when I'm done and retired
is to like kind of head the fight team
up so I'll just have all these hopefully
wrestlers that are coming up underneath
me I'll have learned what I need to
learn and help guide them through that
and I want maybe 10 to 15 guys you know
not a crazy huge team but guys that are
all on a mission on that same mindset on
that same wavelength that want to be
world champion and dominate and just
take those guys under my wing so that's
kind of the plan long term for the gym
you and I had an offline conversation a
while ago about and then I've heard you
mention in the Press too
and I love it and that is that you know
the some of these other countries are
getting a lot of recognition for their
wrestlers
because of what their wrestlers are
doing in MMA and I mean I rattled off a
ton of American wrestlers that have
kicked ass and MMA and been world
champions I mean from everybody from Jon
Jones to uh sahuto I mean it's just but
for some reason these other wrestlers
from other countries get like
recognition yeah as if they're almost as
if they're wrestling is superior almost
as if they're like some different breed
and how do you feel about that Bo nickel
no just just to be 100 honest about it
it does bother me I'm like kind of I
feel uh a chip on my shoulder for um
that because I believe what I represent
American wrestling is is number one and
so to see kind of the the excitement and
hype around the other countries and and
what they're doing
I'm like all right
bring your best we'll see what's up
let's do it so to me it's there there
there's you know I'm totally cool to
talk about it and chat about it and you
know have a conversation I don't know
that that will go a long way in in
people's minds as far as helping them
realize and understand what their
reality is so we gotta fight and that's
what's gonna happen and I'm ready
let's go yeah so we'll do it yeah it
seems kind of crazy I mean uh American
wrestlers
are badass now
would we be better off if we did like
Freestyle Wrestling our whole lives here
in America we would be better off in the
Olympics right like maybe worse off an
MMA definitely yeah because folks
thought the the skills that it takes to
be successful at folk style wrestling
are so different from freestyle one
conditioning is way bigger factor factor
in folk style
um it's a longer match there's less uh
there's more kind of
I guess scramble situations actions more
stuff that's going to be taxing to you
you have to get up off bottom you don't
just get let up right which is what what
is that right like I don't know I don't
know so I always like Freestyle but to
me folk style wrestling is really true
pure wrestling like that's what it's
about it's about I'll get a takedown if
you want to get away you got to get you
got to earn that you got to get away I'm
gonna hold you down on the ground or and
and roll you over to your back and pin
you you know or if you try to grab a
hold of me or you grab my leg or
something and I want to roll and do
something to counter that
I shouldn't lose points for that you're
not controlling me making me do that
it's so so to me I I prefer folk style
wrestling and it's easily Superior in
MMA it's like not even really comparable
you just look at I mean I don't I can
say that but you can look at the stats
too look at like guys that wrestle
exclusively freestyle or Greco
and how successful they were and not
only how successful they were but how
successful were they at implementing
wrestling game which
there's really not a lot of examples but
guys that did folk style wrestling you
can clearly see them implementing the
wrestling game
well I mean it's going to be cool
there's you're going to be coming face
to face with some of these foreign
wrestlers in the future and like you
said we'll find out by fighting what a
beautiful thing like oh you think you
could beat me well let's fight yeah okay
we can do it I'm ready when you watch
their wrestling what do you think
it's like you know it's like uh they got
a specific style and I think everybody
gets so impressed by it because they
are they're discipline and Relentless
and they have a game plan and focus on
what they want to do and it's like
that doesn't really to me make you
special it's like cool dude like I gotta
know a thousand guys that do that like
it's not really anything that's unique I
think that I do respect
their approach to the sport and I think
that some guys in fighting get a little
too LAX party like I'm gonna go out and
be crazy and then I'm gonna go whip ass
and it's like all right cool man but I
like the that's just not my mindset my
mindset is all in discipline focused
commitment and I think a lot of their
guys do kind of have that so I I respect
that and I respect the challenge like
they're gonna come at me with everything
and you know that's what I want I want
to be the best in the world I don't want
to beat a bunch of guys that aren't good
and then call myself the best in the
world like I want to be the best guys
and know I'm the best and so if they're
if they're the best guys then then let's
run it let's go
uh we're putting together kind of like
the Jocko fuel fight team right now and
with the you and the rootolo brothers
the Rotolo Brothers freaking awesome uh
I keep calling them kids is that bad
controls technically I've literally
known them since they were little ones
they were like eight years seven years
old or whatever but so I call them kids
and I am also 50 almost two years old so
that's but I'm falling into that like
old person trap everyone's a kid right
well anyways I've we've got the two
young men there you go the Rotolo
Brothers you know
um they're great guys great attitudes
and now your Jocko fuel team which is
awesome and we just want to build it out
where we have look to me it's not just
like oh this person's popular or this
person's winning but like who is living
the lifestyle that
we are about and so you clearly are
about that so it's been awesome I know
we kind of just got that uh done a
couple maybe a month ago or something
like that no one really knows yet
because I don't like do that big
promotion thing yeah but I guess they'll
know now but yeah that's awesome so
hopefully we can we can give you some
big support definitely that you're doing
yeah I'm excited to be on the team you
know there's uh there's really no team
I'd rather be on if it's a good fit it
makes a lot of sense and doing a lot of
good things so yeah I'm hyped appreciate
you freaking outstanding well so what's
next what do we got we got the kid
coming we got some fighting sometime
yeah you know next year the next main
thing is is go kill some elk I'm gonna
oh yeah I got a couple of Elkins so I'm
really going I got Colorado and New
Mexico all right oh nice yeah nice I'm
excited and you're just bow hunter just
archery yeah yeah I mean I don't really
look down on
hunting with a rifle but archery is
where it's at yeah so I'm an archery guy
yeah have you done a lot of elk hunting
before so
basically two years ago was my first
experience elk hunting I did it with a
rifle and it was great and I loved it
but it's basically what happened was I
wanted to get into archery hunting at
that time I had been shooting my bow for
two months and I was like
all right that doesn't really make sense
for me to go try to kill an elk right
now and so I was like I need to train
some So the plan was train a year next
year or excuse me last year
go get go get one go get after it but
then I had fights end of September so I
was like Frank I can't do it so now I
was like get me a fight before September
give me a fight in you know July and I
was like boom got it done now I got
September to to go get after it so
that's gonna be like my plan every year
is fighting you know July September get
after the elk and then get back on it
hell yeah that's gonna be awesome
um I'll be out there too I'll be in I'll
be in Utah beautiful and
where can people find you so we got we
got Bo nickel.com that's where you can
find
um the scrap life also scraplife.com is
on there I didn't see 27 17. where
what's the website for that it's
2717recovery.com okay yeah so I need to
update the website so this really new no
just kind of launched the product the
last few weeks and uh yeah yeah 27 17
recovery bowenickle.com and then you're
on Instagram at no bickel1 no Bickel one
is there a joke behind that
so basically when I was in high school
my buddy I was like
17 I was like yo I should make an
Instagram like what should I do it I
don't know what bow nickel and he was
like how about no Bickle and I was like
all right this is my buddy Jack and I
was like that's it it's done so it just
it wasn't even me it was Jack Jack bass
okay so on Instagram your no pickle one
on Twitter you're just no Bickle
and then Facebook you're actually just
yourself that bow nickel just myself
there you go
um that gets us up to speed right yeah
Echo Charles you got any questions yes I
seen you were taking notes let's go I
don't know what you're doing over there
uh so when was last time you played
football I knew it representation
football questions coming so the last
time I actually played football
um I don't know I wouldn't count this as
playing football so I'll say two things
I I played
touch football
over Thanksgiving when I was in college
like 2018 with a bunch of my buddies and
uh but I did a workout in the last like
two years probably with uh my buddy
Micah Parsons he plays for the Cowboys
now and uh we did a little a little
speed workout running some 40s and doing
stuff like that so
I'm down to play football anytime that's
fun yeah so uh in what was that high
school right that was when you were that
was when I was actually playing like
yeah sophomore high school year what
position did you play so I played
receiver yeah yeah yeah
Echo was received let's go he was a lot
smaller back then
yeah got you that's your question that's
it and he went over everything
everything I was wondering so okay good
to go right on man uh bo any closing
thoughts from you man I'll just thank
you for for having me on this was really
fun to fun to chat kind of weird to go
back over my whole life but uh it's good
so yeah thank you it's I mean to me you
know obviously a lot of times I have
military folks on here and we get to
hear their story of where where they
were at what they were doing but I mean
dude to here sit here with a national
champion that where you have this
historical record of what you were
thinking at that time I think that's
pretty awesome and um
thanks for joining us for sure and and
you know thanks for setting a great
example
um for wrestlers for Fighters but just
for people as well uh you know your
post-fight interview is pretty awesome I
you don't see too many people with that
attitude and uh I think we're all
looking forward to watching you chase
and win
your next championship UFC and also
thank you for bringing forth the next
generation of American fighters let's go
let's go I love it right on
and with that Bo nickel has left the
building
Echo Charles yes up here at camp we just
doing some Jiu Jitsu some wrestling
um
bow nickel doesn't trade doesn't wrestle
very much only 100 matches a year when
he's six years old only 93 of his waking
hours
uh no it was awesome to have him on and
very cool definitely and we talked a lot
offline we have to do another podcast
where we talk a little bit more of his
training protocols yeah I apologize you
know like we just didn't get in we got
we touched on in the podcast But like
after the podcast when we were sitting
around we kind of like started talking
about it and then we just started going
deep yeah so we'll come back he'll come
back we'll do a better job we'll make it
happen but one thing we definitely
talked about
is the need for fuel yep talk of you
[Music]
uh you're training you're wrestling
you're doing Jiu Jitsu you're lifting
you're getting after it you can't get
after it without fuel
did if you didn't put fuel in your car
where are you going no you're not going
nowhere yeah
so we want to go somewhere yes yeah get
your full good job if you go to
jockeyfield.com get the hydrate get the
greens I've had greens at Camp yeah I
brought them yeah well they did a good
job in supplying they did Supply them as
well I brought some as well but it's a
good way it's a good thing to have in
the breakfast area time
you know because you know I don't you
know I don't like to eat a lot of
breakfast usually I don't eat any
breakfast yeah I'm with you but having
that little nice little
greens package yeah it's kind of a good
deal yeah yeah another thing hydrate
Draco Hydra have you had chocolate
hydrate every day
[Music]
this has been clutch yeah because let's
face it when you're training Jiu Jitsu
it's summertime you're gonna sweat the
winter time of course you're in a
wrestling room you're in a jiu jitsu
room it's going to be hot in there too
you're gonna be sweating get Jocko
hydrate it's basically what you sweat
out it puts back into you yeah that's
what happens you sweat out minerals and
it replenishes them it also has vitamins
there it's got like 100 100 grams of uh
of vitamin C yeah yeah sorry 100
milligrams of Vitamin C not 100 grams
100 milliliters of vitamin C the
electrolyte and you know and all the
electrolytes that you need yeah and
that's a big deal so the
you know how like okay so basically
electrolytes and look I don't want to go
deep into the scientific elements of
this whole thing the Bro Science
elements no no no no no that's the real
one the real one that I looked up but
but in a nutshell there's a good way to
even kind of look at it right is to
electrolytes are like the electrical
signals you know that or the chemicals
that bring the electrical signals like
through you know to your muscles or
whatever
so I'm like all right so you got it you
sweat all that stuff out and then so
because of course I'm gonna be like hey
why don't you just want to just drink
water it's no problem
but when you don't have those
electrolytes like Optical okay so we did
this workout
me Pete Roberts Jason calipo known for
CrossFit scenarios obviously well he's a
champion CrossFit yeah so we did my
workout
we did
his work out and his workout
he he didn't make it up he did it before
but his workout was bench press 135
pounds for 100 Reps for time fourth time
so you could get it the you know he
makes it a competition so you could get
it the fastest so and then we did some
weird ab thing that I never did before
by the way like you ever got an AB cramp
like an abdominal cramp the only way I
get no honestly normally I get I'll tell
you when I get abdominal cramps trains
usually worked out ran transujitsu hard
training Jiu Jitsu get home I'm like
laying in my bed and like go to like
turn on the light and it's just like
cramped yeah so that's my normal so I
don't know what you're about to tell me
no after the ab thing you know like and
the thing is like when you've done the
app thing you really feel it you're like
oh this is some app stuff my app's not
used to and then I turned a certain way
like right after before I even stood up
I turned a certain way and like it
flexible you know and you're just laying
there and you gotta you gotta like
mentally like get past it or whatever
anyway so it's like so all in one the
whole thing my workout yeah usually I
just do my workout I'm done so I did my
workout freaking the bench press
challenge which I lost by the way next
time I'll win which is embarrassing yes
let's face it yeah let's face it I lost
yes but Pete one and hey look we
congratulations good for Pete you know
good for Pete I really hope he's happy
with it but either we seem real happy
about it
and then I mean he's pretty pumped right
yeah he beat you yes and let's face it
beating you would be cool it would be
cool yeah it would be cool to beat you
but he also beat Jason Khalifa and Jason
sleep is a legit professional athlete
yeah and he made up the challenge yeah
he threw it out that's interesting yeah
you know he was mad
he's gonna want some Revenge yeah and
and rightly so because even I wanted to
breathe in damn but the point is oh and
then and I didn't eat anything that day
by the way was this even fair do we need
to edit this out I feel bad no I know I
wasn't even part of this but I feel bad
it's all over so good for Pete oh it's
already oh yeah results are out oh yeah
we're just recapping right is it
trending on Twitter
either way so I go straight from there
to training and I train like look did I
train 10 Rounds no but I did two
workouts mine and Jason Clippers and
then trained I think it was like four or
five rounds
guess what I had right after yeah
oh yeah good as new goodness no more
cramps no cramps for sure all right so
Jocko fuel hydrate greens go we've been
drinking go like it's going out of style
out here yeah because you're out here
let's face it when you train this much
in a day
you're gonna be you're gonna need a
little go and and another thing there's
not a lot of sleeping going on
people are staying up late people are
you know sure even the Jiu-Jitsu class
ends
at like nine but then somebody's got a
question someone wants to catch another
round somebody wants to do this well
somebody wants to work a guard pass all
of a sudden you're like a little bit
hungry so you go to the chow hall oh
some people are explaining something oh
you met a guy that you met last year
he's wanted to talk about this thing oh
yeah how's that next thing you know you
get back down to your cabin and it's
freaking
11 you know 38. and you got to brush
your teeth and you got to take your
super Grill and you gotta take your coal
your your your joint Warfare
and you got to take your time more then
you got to brush your teeth floss
here now it's 1207. alarm clock's going
off in four hours in your case in my
case anyways you're gonna need some go
get it darkerfuel.com Mulk how many
mulks have you been having a day here
average yeah like three like three
sometimes four I've been having like
three four a day yeah pre-meal is what
I've been doing and then I think oh I
just you know have one before I go down
there and then I'll have them post meal
I eat two meals a day that's four so
there you go milk
get what you need uh you can get this
stuff at Wawa you can get vitamin shop
GNC military commissaries
AAFES Hanford Dash stores wake Fern
ShopRite HEB Meyer
by the way like these stores are
starting to bring in the full line it's
awesome Meyer full line uh heb's been
just getting after it
um Harris teeter's just brought in every
so you're gonna see everything so when
you see it get it you know you want to
be stronger you want to be smarter you
want to be faster you want to be better
and if you want to sell this stuff for
your school
you don't sell this stuff at your school
you go to school you got you teach kids
uh educational stuff
maybe you teach them Jiu Jitsu maybe you
teach them CrossFit maybe you teach them
strength and conditioning maybe you
teach them power lifting maybe you teach
them archery I don't know what you're
teaching people but if you're teaching
people and you want to bring this stuff
into your school email JF sales
jackofuel.com set up a wholesale account
that's what we're doing anyways
jockoffuel.com
get some also origin USA hey we're out
here yeah we're here currently origin
Jiu Jitsu emerging Camp
brought to you by origin yeah origin uh
uh American-made apparel started with
geese and still has keys the besties
actually hands down bro that new one
that black guy oh two years like the
fashion side yeah I know I know what's
going on unless all made of America
right here right here from the cotton
all the way to the ghee but not just
geese
[Music]
uh jeans boots they got some good
jackets
the kilo the heavy like those because
I've been seeing those around I'm like
oh man some that I've never seen before
hey let me just put this out there it's
the end of August currently you need a
hoodie for this winter for this fall you
need a hoodie get yourself an
American-made hoodie don't buy a hoodie
that's made by communist buy a biohood
that's made by Americans
that's my recommendation it'll be better
for you it'll be better for the
environment it'll be better for the
economy it'll be better for freedom
it'll just be better
get a kilo hoodie originusa.com go get
some yeah it's cool they got something
for everybody by the way into hunting
hunt gear YouTube
just regular normal stuff working out
freaking RTR skin yeah the whole the
whole the whole deal originusa.com check
it out Jack also Jacques door called
Jocko store this is the uh you know the
the guys that are kind of in the game
discipline equals Freedom representing
in the game on the path if you will so
you can get your stuff um you know you
like the the idea of good
something bad happens good will come out
of it can represent that as well um also
we have the shirt Locker which is a new
shirt every month a subscription
scenario
I've seen a lot of people representing
the Sherlock oh yeah up here it's
interesting because I have this one on
right now the toxic productivity and a
lot of people haven't seen it in
multiple they said oh that's a good
shirt yeah what do you say multiple what
are you talking about
my estimate
seven to ten people okay that's multiple
for sure and yeah it's only in like what
like the period that I've seen a bunch
of people which is only like maybe one
and a half hours yeah all right straight
Locker yes call the shirt Locker it's on
jockostore.com hey check out
primalbeef.com where we got Sean glass
selling steak we're selling steak hell
yeah we got badass steak we got Burgers
like just get it
great grass-fed grain and fruit finished
with fruit you want a cow that was
eating apples right apples sure eating a
grape eating a pear I'm starting to
sound like Theo Vaughn over here
so check it out primalbeef.com see what
you get see what you can get into you
need some steak also subscribe to the
podcast also subscribe to Jocko
underground also subscribe to our
YouTube channel also subscribe to
originusa YouTube channel also subscribe
to Jungle fuel YouTube channel
psychological warfare flipsidecanvas.com
by cool stuff to hang on your wall by
Dakota Meyer I've written a bunch of
books you know what they are get the
books I've signed a bunch of books roll
up here yeah how many people come up to
me and say hey what thank you for
writing leadership strategy and tactics
oh man you
oh dang plenty
uh multiple we'll say multiple yeah yeah
in this case in this case it's more than
30 yeah no I believe it because I
witnessed it's more than 30. I mean I've
say I've signed at least oh um
I'll probably sign 70 books I've seen
three here there you go and you didn't
even write a single book no a single
real word in any of them no just made
the cover oh wait which one did you make
the cover for uh leadership strategy oh
dang I forgot about that
well how much credit do you take for
that honestly none until right now no
but I mean I I give you a crappy
PowerPoint that like basically has the
design on it yes and then you clean it
up and put it in the proper format yes
and you want credit for that
also known as making the cover okay okay
all right
bro I'm taking it where I can go over
here okay so you can get a book Echo
Charles made the cover
yeah you know a lot of people think
that's the most important thing well you
know I'll do what we can over here
anyways bunch of books you know what
they are go get them hey also Warrior
Kid books I signed all kinds of work
kids are playing Jiu Jitsu now they're
playing as Jujitsu because they got the
warrior kid books they're doing pull-ups
they're getting A's in their math
classes they're on the path get the
warrior kid books with people that you
know
you you're thinking like well how could
they can they be I'm telling you there's
no way that this many people come up and
talk to me about how these books help
their kids if they're not freaking
outstanding
so check out the way the warrior kid
books check out about faced by hackworth
I signed one of those while we're here
no two two of those while we're here
and extreme ownership dichotomy
leadership leadership strategy and
tactics discipline because I sign a lot
of discipline equals Freedom up here
probably
14 of those estimated 17 maybe
anyways that's what we're doing
um
a bunch of books get them essonfront.com
if you have issues you want to improve
the leadership inside your organization
go to slamfont.com you can come to one
of our events we can come to you you can
do our online training which is
available at extreme ownership.com where
you can take online courses you can you
can learn Jiu Jitsu online
which is a real physical thing but you
can also learn
to lead
so check out extreme ownership.com learn
about life learn about home life learn
about leading your family learn about
leading your boss
learn about leadership extreme
ownership.com and if you want to help
service members active and retired you
want to help their families you want to
help gold star families check out
Markley's mom
Ma Lee She's Got an amazing charity
organization and if you want to donate
or you want to get involved go to
America's Mighty Warriors dot org also
check out
heroesandhorses.org that is Micah Fink
he's got a
charity
where he takes people up into the
Wilderness I mean deep into the
Wilderness and they go in rivers cold
Rivers They Ride horse back
they eat meat
they have no junk food they have no cell
phones they get out there they get lost
and they get found Heroes and horses.org
also thanks to Bo nickel for joining us
and
just just a great guy as you could tell
we wish him the best and we will enjoy
watching him in pursuit of UFC gold and
representing America and American
fighters so thanks once again to Beau
if you want to connect with us by the
way Bo is Bo nickel.com he's at
Instagram at no bickel1 he's on Twitter
at no Bickel he's on Facebook at Bow
nickel of course that goes out of
controls I'm at chocolate willink
just be careful because there's an
algorithm on there and you might
accidentally follow somebody
that you didn't mean to and now all of a
sudden you're following random people so
just be careful yeah just watch out for
that one then what do you do what are
you doing you accidentally follow
someone I don't know man dude that
happened to me two times so I'm
following and you know I'm not gonna say
the name obviously but I just I just let
it ride you know whatever and if if
thankfully great people you know normal
people whatever so but yeah if they got
annoying I don't know maybe unfollow me
I don't even know where the follow
button is yeah I don't even know where
it is but somehow I must have hit it
yeah and so now we're following
here this is how it because I did the I
reversed engineered it and if you click
on like your alerts or whatever you know
the heart with the alert it'll it'll say
like this guy did this and then but if
you're not following it'll say follow
like you'll have a question so you can
easily uh accidentally press follow yes
Jack okay we'll just watch out because
your algorithm will have people that you
may end up following by accident
uh all right well like I said thanks to
Beau for coming out thanks to our
military the members are of our military
who represent America around the world
and who keep us safe and protect our way
of life and also thanks to our police
law enforcement firefighters paramedics
EMTs dispatchers correctional officers
border patrol Secret Service and all
First Responders
thank you for keeping us safe and
protecting us here at home and to
everyone else out there
let's just think about those j7 the Jay
Robinson
wrestler coach Soldier Ranger Vietnam
veteran
his seven fundamentals that he would
teach to Young wrestlers discipline
dedication sacrifice hard work
responsibility accountability and of
course
service
and if you're doing those things
if you're doing those things
you can do anything and you can
definitely stay on the path
and until next time this is Echo and
Jocko
out